foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will be learning who is a business
analyst and business analytics with
Excel but before we begin I would like
to take a quick confirmation from our
viewers if the screen is clearly visible
and the audio is clear if yes kindly
type yes in the chat section and if
there is anything that we can improvise
then do let us know in the chat section
great I can see a lot of positive
responses from our viewers thank you I
think it's clear that we can get started
now before we begin I would like to tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple Technologies so if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn
now without further Ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
discussion
we will get started by understanding the
need for business analysts and how
important is for a company to have a
business analyst on board now followed
by that we will understand the critical
skills and roles and responsibilities of
a business analyst followed by that we
will understand the key knowledge areas
of a business analyst later we will
understand business analytics with Excel
then we will differentiate the two
different key terms that are the
business analyst and data analyst
so as discussed before we will dive a
little deep into business analysis with
Excel where we will get started with the
basic fundamentals of excel then we will
get started with the lookup functions
which are the edge lookup vlookup and X
lookup in Excel and we will also
understand the fundamental functions
which are used in day to day business
analytics followed by that we will learn
sorting and filtering in Excel then we
will have conditional formatting data
validation and the most important part
which is the pivot tables and pivot
charts in Excel and finally we will
understand data analysis with toolpath
so with that we have finished the agenda
I hope I made myself clear with the
agenda now we can get started with our
first topic that is the importance of
business analyst over to our training
experts
we will understand the importance of
business analyst with a short and
interesting story
so meet Rob he runs a cafe in a small
town far away his Cafe is one of the
oldest and most popular eateries in town
Rob's Cafe was usually popular amongst
customers and it was doing very well
until the onset of the deadly Corona
virus
due to covid-19 like other eateries Rob
was forced to shut down his Cafe too
this took a heavy toll on his business
and subsequently he lost his customers
none of his customers visited his Cafe
and this resulted in a huge loss for him
he knew he couldn't afford to close his
business forever as it would take time
for Coronavirus to be eradicated
but he was lost this situation was new
to him and he didn't know how to reopen
his business amidst this pandemic
after a lot of brainstorming he
recollected reading about business
analysts he remembered that business
analysts are professionals who enable a
change in an organization he felt like a
business analyst could help him sort out
his current business problems hence
without wasting any time he set out to
hire a business analyst he hired Ted the
business analyst to help him with his
ongoing business problems Rob entrusted
Ted with reopening the business
the first step Ted took was to have a
discussion with Rob and understand the
business problems and the objectives
that is ideally the first step a
business analyst would take on
discussion with Rob Ted learned that the
business objective was to reopen the
business and get at least 80 percent of
the customer base back in addition to
that Rob also wanted Ted to look for
sustainable ways to reopen and continue
the business in the long run amidst the
pandemic Ted studied the case and he
came up with a few suggestions that he
thought was fit for Rob's business
his first suggestion was to develop an
exclusive home delivery app for Rob's
Cafe
this way Ted knew that business will
improve as customers prefer home
delivery in the current scenario next
Ted suggested that Rob has work from
home meal boxes added to his menu
many professionals are working from home
currently and having work from home meal
boxes would be a good pick for such
Professionals in the middle of a busy
day
Ted's third suggestion was to bring down
the selling cost by providing discount
coupons that can be utilized by
customers
having a discount will enable more
customers to order from Rob's Cafe of
course it was not possible to get the
customer base back without any sort of
price Cuts in the current situation
finally Ted suggested the drop staff
would facilitate home delivery orders
this way he didn't have to lay off his
stuff and at the same time get the home
delivery running so these were a few
suggestions given by Ted yes depending
on the situation business analysts can
take up different approaches
so after the suggestions were accepted
by Rob for the app that began to make
sure that the development went well by
collaborating with the IT team that
became the intermediary between the I.T
team and Rob he provided suggestions to
the team checked the app through user
interface testing and made sure that the
requirements met well
the same applied to the other business
requirements and changes as well Ted
held regular meetings to gauge the
progress and also kept Rob in the loop
and updated him with the status of the
project attending regular catch-ups
helped Rob Kane and insight into the
progress and gave us feedback from time
to time Ted made sure that the entire
case was well documented by doing so he
could always refer to the documents in
the future with similar cases as well
Ted made presentations that showed Rob
the business growth after implementing
the changes and Ted always supported his
presentations with data Rob was very
impressed with Ted's business approach
such an approach not only helped Rob
reopen his business amidst the covid-19
but also helped him get 80 percent of
his customer base back Ted successfully
brought about a positive change in Rob's
business which was highly beneficial
so that is how Ted the business analyst
helped Rob make a business sustainable
this was the importance of having a
business analyst in Rob's organization
don't you think every organization
should have a business analyst well yes
depending on the business domain and the
situation the roles and responsibilities
may vary let's start off and have a look
at a day in the life of a business
analyst through a small story so meet
Angela who is working as a business
analyst in an application development
firm her firm builds applications for
clients depending on their requirements
our next character is Rob he is a
budding entrepreneur with a vision of
setting up his own e-commerce app he
plans on selling several electronic
gadgets like phones laptops cameras Etc
on his app
so what is Rob's First Step well he
approaches Angela's firm one day with
the vision of creating his e-commerce
app Angela and Rob start talking
business and Angela promises to help Rob
with his app creation she assures him
that she will look into his business
requirements and coordinate with him to
get the app running Rob is happy about
it and agrees to cooperate with Angela
regarding all the business requirements
from his end Angela as we know is the
business analyst she starts planning
Rob's project and without any delay she
embarks on this Project's Journey she
has a set of plant steps that will help
her fulfill Rob's requirements
steps she takes is her approach going to
be effective and quick let's find out
the answers to these questions now up
next you can learn about Angela's
approach that helps her deliver Rob's
project smoothly and without any hassles
these steps that we are going to look at
are the typical roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
here we will understand these roles
better with respect to Angela's and drop
story first and foremost Angela
understands Rob's business objectives
problems and requirements without
understanding this do you think Angela
will be able to proceed no hence a
business analyst like Angela understands
the problems related to Rob's business
and comes up with the right solution to
achieve the goals of the business she
brainstorms around what is best suited
for an e-commerce app focusing on
electronic Gadgets in The Next Step
Angela gathers all the necessary
requirements here she understands Rob's
requirements and makes sure that they
are on the same page regarding the
project and its goals both of them
together arrive at a stipulated deadline
for the project completion
she gathers relevant information based
on security of the app the payment setup
needs to login cost of the products and
style to name a few once Angela has an
in-depth understanding of Rob's project
and gathers all the necessary
requirements she starts allocating
Resources by keeping in mind the budget
of the project
here she recognizes and allocates tasks
and resources to the development team
Pas work closely with the development
team to design the solution for a
problem
Angela ensures that the development team
doesn't spend their time understanding
Rob's requirements
in this step along with the development
team she finalizes the software and
tools required to build the project
Angela doesn't rest until the project is
delivered to Rob she continuously
monitors the progress and constantly
provides her feedback to the developing
team with respect to the apps layout
design and other features she gives them
suggestions in order to improve the
application in The Next Step Angela
collects feedback of the Prototype
version of the app from the users
she notes down if the Prototype is fine
or if it requires more work p is
validate if the project is running fine
with the help of use acceptance testing
they verify if the solution being worked
on is in line with the requirements and
ensure that the final product satisfies
the use expectations
Bas also assess the functional and
non-functional requirements after
collecting feedback Angela moves to one
of her most crucial duties and that is
building reports data visualization is a
key skill for any ba in order to gauge
the performance of the app and get
valuable insights from it Angela builds
reports using various data visualization
tools like Tableau power bi and click
view reports can be General reports such
as detailed reports or it can be
dashboard reports such as visualized
reports with multi-dimensional analysis
based on display of business indicators
it is not uncommon for issues to crop up
amidst this entire process hence Angela
conducts regular meetings with the
development team and Rob to solve
problems quickly having these meetings
will help Rob understand the status of
the project and it will also help the
teams proceed in the right path
throughout this project phase Angela
makes sure to maintain transparency on
completion of the project Angela
documents and presents the project
findings to Rob generally business
analysts present the project outcomes to
the stakeholders and clients along with
maintenance reports Angela noted on all
the project learnings and details in a
concise manner this will help her take
better decisions in the future and these
documents will save her time while
implementing the next project now that
she has completed all her duties and
responsibilities with respect to Rob's
project she is ready to deliver the
final e-commerce application to Rob for
use Rob is rest assured that the
application developed by Angela's firm
is apt for his business and just what he
wanted Angela's streamlined approach
made it easier for the project to be
delivered within the stipulated time
period Rob is happy and I'm sure he will
come back to Angela's form for projects
in the future so those responsibilities
that we saw Angela carry out are ideally
the roles and responsibilities for any
business analyst out there
yes some may vary depending on the
company you work for and the project
you're working on if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
business analyst is a professional who
is responsible for Bridging the Gap
between I.T and business teams
they use analytics to evaluate processes
determined requirements deliver
data-driven Solutions and generate
reports to Executives and stakeholders
business analyst is an individual who is
a part of the business operation and
works closely with the technology team
to improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also help in
assisting in integration and testing of
new Solutions
growing a career in a field with high
demand such as business analysis could
be a challenge and competition for
business analyst positions can be
intense so you should have a clear
understanding of the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
a ba should successfully identify and
recognize the organization's business
objective they should understand the
business problems and think of a
lucrative business solution
they need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders allocate the right
resources and improve the existing
business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst
Bas interact with the development team
to design the solution for solving a
particular problem
they often need to spend a certain
amount of time in meetings in order to
save the development team from spending
their time and understanding the
stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application as to what our
features need to be added and what
functionalities should the application
contain and also implement the newly
designed features that a business needs
while Bas identify the needs Define the
features right use cases uncover
business rules and manage issues they
should also gauge the functional and
non-functional requirements in a
business
analysts run meeting with stakeholders
and other authorities hence discussing
issues with the client face-to-face can
do wonders and even help in solving
problems quickly they engage with
Business Leaders and users to understand
how data-driven changes to products
Services software and Hardware can
improve efficiency and add value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line with the client's requirements
they also ensure that the product
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally based right documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights
they also deliver maintenance reports
they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a project
business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often referred to
as soft skills the skills for a business
analyst are not only acquired through
training but through experience and
combined with the ability to understand
situations and the motive behind the
problem so let's have a look at the top
skills to become a successful business
analyst the first skill we have is
understanding the business objective
for a business analyst it is important
to know the goals and objectives of the
business it is advised that business
analysts should have a good knowledge of
the business operations in his or her
organization
a business analyst should understand the
problems related to the business and
come up with the right solution business
analysts who resolve the problems that
have been identified and not avoid them
they work on individual actions and
tasks that will build towards the
achievement of the goals of the business
objectives of the business can be to
expand customer base in order to
increase sales scale up production so
that it is in line with the revenue
growth improved revenue streams through
increasing perceived product value or
increase in marketing budget according
to the revenue
business analysts should have the
Natural Curiosity and determination to
continue learning and figuring out how
things fit together
even as business analysts become
managers it is important to stay in
touch with the industry and its changes
the next important skill of business
analyst would have is analytical and
critical thinking
now there is a famous quote by Thomas
Alba Edition which says
five percent of the people think 10
percent of the people think they think
and the other 85 percent would rather
die than think
business analysts are paid to think a
business analyst would be able to
analyze and interpret the client's
requirements clearly
business analysts required good focus in
order to collect and understand the
needs of the client
critical thinking involves evaluating
several options before arriving at the
desired solution
in certain situations a stakeholder may
give a requirement that's not
necessarily tied up to any business
value but rather to their own increased
convenience applying critical thinking
demands not taking all the statements of
the stakeholders for granted critical
thinking allows the business analyst to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those that
should be given a low priority a
business analyst must be creative in
order to reach stated goals but
resources are limited and the conditions
are non-ideal
the third important skill for a business
analyst is communication and
interpersonal skills
understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession
if you are unable to clearly specify and
communicate requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual you have to speak several
different languages while conveying the
same message
business analysts apply communication
skills at every point the use
communication and interpersonal skills
when the project is launched while
Gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final solution
listening reading and writing skills are
very critical for a business analyst
they should be capable of facilitating
meetings business analysts use verbal
and written communication to convey
ideas Concepts facts and opinions to a
variety of stakeholders
non-verbal communication skills enable
the effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement posture facial expressions
gestures and eye contact
effective listening allows the business
analyst to accurately understand
information that has been communicated
verbally
fourth in our list of skills we have
negotiation and cost benefit analysis
being a successful business analyst
requires working with and interacting
with many people
these people include clients Business
Leaders project team members project
stakeholders vendors private sector
Representatives industry leaders and so
forth business analysts negotiate at
every turn during the course of a
project
at the initial stage of a project
negotiation skills are used to determine
what should be included in the vision of
the project as details emerge
negotiation skills are used by all
parties involved to determine which
requests become requirements and which
requirements have higher priority
as the project progresses negotiation
skills help to determine the functional
design which fulfill the requirements
technical decisions also require
negotiation skills business analysts
also perform cost benefit analysis to
conduct an assessment of the benefits
and costs anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analysts that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not
business analysts should be able to
achieve a profitable outcome for your
company while finding a solution for the
client that makes them happy
this Balancing Act demands the ability
to influence a mutual solution and
maintain professional relationship
up next we have our fifth skill that is
decision making
the quality of decisions made by
business analyst is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact on the
company's business thus it is important
for every business analyst to think from
all aspects before presenting the
decision or strategy
they must be having good problem solving
skills as well business analysts should
have an act to think out of the box and
find a solution to problems majorly a
business analyst follows five major
steps while making a decision
these steps are Define the problem
find and Define the alternative
approaches
evaluate the alternative approaches
make the decision based on these
approaches and test and finally
implement the solution
while some may argue that the technical
team is responsible for Designing the
solution the business analyst Still
Remains instrumental in ensuring that
the design conforms to the requirements
that have been approved
now that we have reached halfway through
the skills I would like to ask all our
viewers to please subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn
moving on
we have another really important
business analyst skill that is idea
about programming languages
business analysts should have a good
Hands-On programming knowledge for
performing better and faster analysis of
data
knowledge of R and python is highly
beneficial
business analysts can help solve complex
Problems by writing efficient codes
both R and python have a vast collection
of libraries and packages for data
manipulation data wrangling data
visualization and data analytics
some of these libraries are numpy pandas
D player titier ggplot and matplotlib
in addition to these it is good to
understand statistical software like SAS
and SPSS using these programming
languages such as python RN SAS you can
analyze and visualize large data sets as
well as create machine learning models
for making future business predictions
the seventh skill in our list is
creation of reports and dashboards
a business analyst should be proficient
in using various business intelligence
tools for creating reports and
dashboards
reports created by business analysts can
be General reports such as detailed
report grouped report crosstab report
column report query report data entry
report Etc or it can be dashboard
reports such as visualized Report with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators dashboard
reports are developed by business
analysts to solve business decision
making problems different from the
tabular interface of the general report
the dashboard report adopts the canvas
like operation interface knowledge of
Tableau power bi and click view are
required to make different types of
reports depending on the business
requirements
now the eighth skill in our list of
skills is database and SQL
business analysts often work with data
that is structured in nature hence to
store and process this data they should
have knowledge of relational databases
such as Microsoft SQL Server Oracle
database mySQL database as well as nosql
databases
also having hands-on experience with SQL
is a must for a business analyst to
access retrieve manipulate and analyze
data so they should be able to write
data definition and data manipulation
commands such as create update delete
and insert
Microsoft Excel is the ninth skill in
our list
Excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and Powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with data
business analysts use Excel to perform
various calculations budget analysis and
data analysis to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
the sort filter and create pivot tables
to summarize the data
business analysts can also create
different charts and graphs using Excel
to generate Dynamic reports related to a
business problem
business analysts can use Excel to
create Revenue growth models for new
products based on new customer forecasts
when planning an editorial calendar for
a website business analyst can list out
dates and topics in a spreadsheet
when creating a budget for a small
product they can list expense categories
in a spreadsheet update it monthly and
create a chart to show how close the
product is to budget across each
category
business analysts can calculate customer
discounts based on monthly purchase
volume by product
they can even summarize customer Revenue
by product to find areas where to build
strong customer relationships
finally in the list of skills we have
documentation and presentation
you could have all the industry
experience in the world but if it's
paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all
a business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in a concise and compact form
they should also be confident about
presenting the findings and conclusions
in front of the stakeholders and clients
organized documentation will help you
communicate technical Concepts to
non-technical employees it is important
that a business analyst notes down all
the details that they learn from their
projects
this will help them take better
decisions in the future also if similar
problems Arise at a later stage they can
implement the same solution thereby
saving a lot of time and unwanted
problems
while business analysts are generally
not responsible for making decisions
regarding project Solutions decision
making skills are still important for
understanding Gathering and presenting
relevant information to assess decision
makers with selecting the optimal
solution
with that we have covered our top skills
for a business analyst if you have any
questions related to the skills that we
covered then please put it in the chat
section our team will help you solve
your queries now let me tell you how
simply learn can help you grow your
career in business analytics and help
you become a business analyst
so let me search for simply learn here
this is the simply learn website
and on the search bar let me look for
business
analyst
you can see
there are a few courses related to
business analyst so let me open these
two courses
so let's go to the first course
so this is the business analyst Masters
program
now this program is endorsed education
provider is iiba
now if you look on the right we have the
different courses that will be covered
as part of this Masters program
so there is introduction to business
analysis certified business analytics
professional you'll also learn about
agile and scrum
there's business analytics with Excel
will also get training in SQL less
Tableau training
and you'll also get to work on business
analyst Capstone projects
if I scroll down
now here are the tools that will be
covered as part of this course so this
Microsoft Excel Zeta Tableau power bi
postgres SQL
then this plan box Target process
and others
here you can see the
program advisors
and if I scroll further
is the entire course content we have
these are the different courses that you
will be learning in this course
and
after you finish the course you will
receive a certificate which will look
similar to this
so please go ahead and enroll to this
course if you want to start your career
in business analytics now let me take
you to another program
we have postgraduate program in business
analysis now this is in partnership with
Purdue University and endorsed education
provider is iipa
if I scroll down you can see here the
key features of this course you'll get
podio postgraduate program certification
Alumni Association membership
master classes from Purdue faculties
enrollment in simply learns job assist
there's 170 Plus hours of Blended
learning 11 plus Hands-On projects
custom projects in three domains
if I scroll further
on the right you can see this is the
produce certification that you will
receive after finishing the course
and you will also get the certificate
received by International Institute of
business analysis that is iiba
let's scroll down
you also have the advantage for
enrolling to Simply learn job assist
program so you will get IM jobs Pro
membership for six months resume
assistance and career monitoring you'll
also have interview preparation and
career affairs
now here you can see the program details
so you will learn about an introduction
to business analysis certified business
analysis professional this is Island
scrum
business analytics with Excel Tableau
training business analyst Capstone
project
and you also have the opportunity to
enroll for some electives so we have
Purdue University business analysis
Master Class
you can also enroll to a power bi course
and there's Agilent scrum Foundation
if I scroll down
here you can see the skills that will be
covered as part of this program so this
business analysis this allitiation and
collaboration requirement analysis
planning and monitoring
let me click on view more you have
strategy analysis dashboarding
wireframing there's data visualization
statistical analysis using Excel SQL
database
this requirement lifecycle management
and lots more
so these are the tools that will be
covered in this course we have Microsoft
Excel 0 Focus
plan box that's rally power bi process
SQL that's version one target process
and others
and now this is the important part
though these are the industry related
projects that you will get to work on
once you enroll to this course so the
first project is canteen ordering system
for Unilever
we also have Library management system
for Stanford University that is WhatsApp
pay and you can see the description of
these projects
mentioned below
and
you also have
Hospital management system for Mayo
Clinic
there are course advisors for this
course now they are directly related to
Purdue University
if you scroll further this is the
learner's profile and how the industry
trend has been for business analysts
so please go ahead and enroll to this
program if you
really want to start your career or you
want to grow your career as a business
analyst now here is a quick roadmap that
depicts what a fresher needs to possess
to become a business analyst
first they need to have a graduation
degree in a related field then knowledge
of SQL and relational database is very
important
thirdly a fresher should have good
hands-on experience with programming
languages and that's a prerequisite
and finally they need to have good
communication skills to nail the role of
a business analyst
up next we have the roadmap that depicts
what an experienced professional needs
to possess to become a business analyst
firstly they should have good knowledge
of the domain they are currently working
in
next they should know how to write SQL
queries
an experienced professionals should be
good with programming languages
in addition to that they need to have
good communication and negotiation
skills
finally they should be good at creating
interactive reports using business
intelligence tools
in addition to that having a
certification offered by International
Institute of business analysis such as
certified business analysis professional
would be highly beneficial let's now
learn the business analysis knowledge
areas
first up we have business analysis
planning and monitoring now this
knowledge area describes the tasks used
to organize and coordinate business
analysis efforts it involves planning
business analysis approach stakeholder
engagement business analysis governance
as well as Information Management then
we have initiation and collaboration
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to prepare and conduct
elicitation activities and confirm the
results
it also includes communicating business
analysis information and stakeholder
engagement
the third knowledge area we have is
requirements life cycle management
so this knowledge area describes the
task that we perform in order to manage
and maintain requirements throughout
their life cycle it covers the creation
changes prioritization traceability and
governance processes
fourth in our list we have strategy
analysis
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to identify the business need
address that need and align the change
strategy within the Enterprise
you need to analyze the current state
Define the future State assess risk and
Define change strategy
then we have requirements analysis and
design definition this knowledge area
describes the tasks used to organize
requirements specify and model
requirements it also validates and
verifies information and identifies
solution options the final knowledge
area we have is solution evaluation this
knowledge area measures the solution
performance analyzes performance
measures SS solution limitations and
recommends actions to increase solution
value now let's discuss two of the most
widely used methodologies in any
business analysis process
these methods are popularly used in the
industries to ensure smooth running of
projects the first methodology we are
going to talk about is the agile
methodology
Ajay is an incremental and iterative
approach to project management and
software development it helps team
deliver value to their customers faster
and with fewer obstacles teams can
manage a project by breaking it up into
several stages and involving constant
collaboration with stakeholders along
with continuous Improvement and
iteration at every stage
so the steps involved in an agile
project development includes
planning the project in terms of
business goals budget time duration for
completing the project and resource
needed
then we have designing the solution for
the problem at hand
the third step is developing the
solution this could be a software a
website an application Etc
it's done by the development team
next we have testing the product in the
next step of the life cycle
deploying the developed product to check
if it's working fine and finally we have
reviewing the product and getting
feedback from customers clients
stakeholders Etc now in agile
methodology the entire work is broken
down into several sprints after each
Sprint we get a shippable product and
that product is reviewed by the client
or the stakeholder
the suggestions are Incorporated in the
next print
here you can see we have Sprint 1 Sprint
2 and Sprint 3 and all of them have the
six steps that we discussed in the agile
methodology process now let's discuss
the scrum methodology
scrum is a subset of the agile framework
it is one of the most widely used
lightweight process Frameworks for Agile
development
you can easily collaborate develop and
deliver complex products of the highest
possible value
scrum empowers the development team and
supports working in small teams like 8
to 10 members scrum significantly
increases productivity and reduces time
this process enables organizations to
adjust smoothly to rapidly changing
requirements and produce a product that
meets evolving business goals ok so the
concepts and practices in scrum can be
divided into three categories
first we have three rules
a product owner owns the product backlog
and writes user stories and acceptance
criteria they are responsible for
prioritizing the product backlog and
deciding the release date and the
content a product owner is the one who
is responsible for the return on
investment or Roi of the product a scrum
Master is a servant who encourages and
demands self-organization from the
development team they enable close
cooperation across all roles and
functions addresses resource issues and
Disobedience of scrum practices a
development team comprises individuals
working together to develop and deliver
the requested and committed product
increments the development team builds
the product and includes all the
expertise necessary to deliver the
potential shippable product each Sprint
the second category comprises of three
artifacts the product backlog is an
ordered list of the features and
requirements needed to complete the
project the list can include bugs or
defects that need to be resolved
features that must be added and other
technical or Project work your team has
to complete before the project is over
Sprint backlog includes only what needs
to be completed during the current
Sprint it often has greater detail and
more complete user stories than the rest
of the product backlog once created no
one can add to the Sprint backlog except
the development team the product
increment is the version of the product
that will be delivered at the end of
each Sprint while the Sprint backlog
outlines what must be completed within a
Sprint the product increment details the
outcome of all that work
the increment is a prototype or working
version of the final product expected by
the customer the final category we have
is Sprint ceremonies
there are four ceremonies in total in
Sprint planning the team meets and
decides what they need to complete in
the coming Sprint Sprint review is a
type of meeting in which the team
demonstrates what they shipped in the
Sprint
in the Sprint retrospective the team
reviews their work identifying what they
did well and what didn't go as planned
so that they can make the next print
better daily scrum is a stand-up meeting
or a very short like 15 to 20 minutes
meeting for the team to make sure that
they are all on the same page
now let's talk about the average annual
salary of a business analyst according
to pay scale the average annual salary
of a business analyst in the United
States is 68 973 dollars while in India
a business analyst can earn nearly 6
lakh rupees per annum now talking about
the companies hiring for business
analysts we have the Indian e-commerce
payment system and financial technology
company paytm American immensely
cognizant and British Dutch
multinational Oil and Gas Company sell
we also have Cisco the search engine
giant Google and Dell finally in our
list of companies we have Ernst and
Young Global limited American
multinational computer technology
corporation Oracle and British
multinational Investment Bank and
financial services company Barclays with
that let's discuss the top business
analysis tools and software used by
business analysts we have the widely
used spreadsheet application Microsoft
Excel web-based kanban style list making
application Trello relational database
Management systems such as MySQL
Microsoft SQL server and postgres SQL
then we have bug tracking and agile
project management product Zera and
Tableau Software for data visualization
okay so let's look at a demo on business
analyst training
oftentimes business analysts work on
structured data using Excel to prepare
reports and dashboards
they do create pivot tables and po
charts to summarize and analyze data
find Trends and insights to make
critical decisions
so in this demo we will work on a sales
data set from the United States and
analyze the total revenue total profit
the quantity sold for different
categories and subcategories of products
across various regions segments cities
Etc
now let me show you the data set first
okay so here is my data set you can see
there are
nearly
9994 rows and we have
17 columns you can see this is a sales
data set and the First Column is of
order date then we have the shipment
date we have the shipment mode next we
have the customer name
that is the customer who purchased the
product we have the segment the country
name there's only United States then we
have the different cities from the US we
have the state names
and if I go to the right you can see the
categories of product
we also have the subcategories
next we have the product name
then we have our sales value now you can
assume this to be in dollars
then we have the quantity that was sold
for each product
then we have the discount column and
finally we have the profit column
so let's analyze this data set using
different charts and graphs
first let's create a pivot table to see
the sales by region and year so here we
want to see the sales of all the years
in different regions of the United
States
so for that I'll click on any cell
inside this data set
go to the insert Tab and here I have the
option to create a pivot table
I'll click on this create pivot table
option and you can see it has selected
my entire data and here I'll choose new
worksheet that is the place where I want
to place this pivot table and let's
click on OK
so you can see it has created a new
sheet which is sheet2
and
let's drag our columns
onto the different sections in this
pivot table Fields so since I want to
know the region
and the year so let's drag the order
date first
and
let's delete
the quarter column so I'll click on
remove field
I don't want this field so I have my
ears first and then
let's drag
region column
under columns
and
we want to know the sales for all the
years in different regions so I'll drag
sales onto values
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready if you want you can go ahead and
rename this row labels and column labels
now with this table ready let's create a
line chart
this will help you analyze your data
better
so what you can do is go to the insert
Tab and here under recommended charts
you can go for line chart you can see
the line chart preview here
and click on OK
there you go
how easily Excel has created a pivot
chart for US based on this pivot table
now if you notice the lines in this
graph you can see the different regions
and here is the legend
now
if you see the yellow line which is
actually for the west region so the
sales had declined from 2014
to 2015 and then it gradually started
increasing from 2015 to 2017 onwards
and if you see the orange line or the
red line it is for the east region
the sales have been continuously
increasing you can see the trend here
similarly
if you see the central region
the sales generated was study from 2014
till 2015 then it increased in 2016 and
after 2016 it became constant
similarly you can analyze the South
Region as well
now let's say you want to know the sales
by each category of product and the
different segments so you can do that as
well let's go to our sheet 1 where we
have our data set
let me click on any cell I'll go to
insert and I'll choose pivot table
here
Let It Be new worksheet I'll click on OK
all right so since we want to know the
sales value again so let's drag sales
onto
values field and now I'll choose
category
under rows so
let's select category under rows
and then
we want to know
for each segment also
so what I can do is
I'll choose segment under columns
you can see I have my pivot table ready
so here you have the furniture office
supplies and Technology as the
categories of products and on the top
you can see consumer corporate home
office has the different segments
now let's create a
visual out of this pivot table so I'll
go to recommended charts and
let's say this time I want to
create a bar chart now this is a
horizontal bar chart
let's click on OK
if I close this
and I bring it to here you can see this
is a nice bar chart
and Below you can see the sales values
and on the y-axis you can see the
different categories of products and in
the legend we have the segments now if
you want you can edit this chart as well
so let's delete
or hide all field buttons on the chart
all right similarly let's do this for
our line chart as well let's hide these
field buttons okay
all right
now
let's suppose we want to know which
segment meet the highest and the lowest
profits so for that you can create a
pivot table as well
so I'll click on any cell go to the
insert tab
and choose pivot table I click on OK
all right now see
we want to know the profit by each
segment
so I'll first choose profit onto values
and
let's drag
the segment column
onto rows so we have our pivot table
ready
now here if you want to know which
segment meet the highest or the lowest
profit you can sort this data so click
on any cell under sum of profit
right click and here you have the short
option
so let's do sort smallest to largest
which is in ascending order
okay so here you can see consumer
segment meet the highest amount of
profit while the home office segment
made the lowest amount of profit now
based on this pivot table you can create
a pie chart let's do that
I'll go to insert and here under
recommended charts I'll select pi
and let's click on OK
there you go we have a nice pie chart
ready
now the gray color Pi represents your
consumer segment which made the highest
amount of profit you can also validate
it from the pivot table
while the blue segment which is actually
home office made the lowest amount of
profit now let's remove this field from
here I'll right click and select hide
all field buttons on the chart
now one thing you can do is you can edit
the chart title
here by default it has shown total we
can rename it to let's say profit by
segment and hit enter
okay
now you can adjust the size of this and
the color of the text if you want you
can do it from here
similarly
let's
add a title to our bar graph as well
so here if you see
there's an option to choose chart title
and
I'll say seals by
segment
and category
okay
similarly let's add a title to
our first line chart that we created
I'll click on the chart title and here
I'll write sales by
year and region
okay
now let me go back to my
data sheet now suppose let's say you
want to know the total units that were
sold for each subcategory of products
and the shipment mode
so here we have the shipment mode and
you want to know the total units that
were sold which is basically this column
the quantity column for each
subcategories of product you can see we
have different subcategories like
bookcases chairs labels The Stables
Furnishings art phones binders Etc
so let's create a pivot table for this
I'll go to the insert tab click on pivot
table
and click on OK
all right now
since we want to know the total units
that were sold let's drag
the quantity column under values
and
I'll choose
the ship mode field under columns
and let's select
sub category under rows
so I have my pivot table ready
now based on this pivot table let's
create a line chart I'll go to the
insert tab click on recommended charts
and let's go to line chart
all right
you can see the preview here and the
Legends which show the
shipment mode Let's click on OK
I'll close this
now
first let's remove these fields I'll
right click and I'll hide all field
buttons
now if you see this one
you can add some styles to your chart
let's modify our chart a bit
let's see I'll select
yeah this one
you can see it has given dots for each
end points which means this is my first
subcategory as you can see the second
subcategory the third subcategory which
is art
then we have binders
so it's really easy to read and
understand the chart well
okay now let's add a chart title
I'll write
quantity
sold
by
sub category
and
ship mode
now you can reduce the size of the
chart title text let's keep it
10. okay
foreign
to create different kinds of maps in
Excel
so suppose
you want to see the states that meet the
highest and the lowest sales in the
United States so you can create a field
map for that so first of all let's go to
our data sheet
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
create a pivot table
click on OK
all right so since we want the
State and the country so let me first
drag country field under rows and then
I'll choose the State field under rows
now let's
drag seals under values
okay
so we have our
pivot table ready now if I sort this
data you can easily know
that California state meet the highest
amount of sales now if I scroll down
below you can see
North Dakota made the lowest amount of
seals
now
let's do one thing let's remove the
grand total so you can go to the design
Tab and under Grant totals you can
select the first option you can see the
grand total has gone
and in order to create a map we need to
adjust this pivot table so I'll click on
United States
I'll right click and
I'll go to field settings
here under
layout and print
I'll click on
show item labels in Tableau format
and I'll also click on
repeat item labels you can see
it will populate United States for all
the rows if I click on OK you can see
the United States have been populated
for all the states
now let me
select this table
or before that let's remove the
subtotal from here I'll close this go to
the design tab under subtotals I'll
choose do not show subtotals okay now
let's
select the table
and I'll actually paste it somewhere
here
now with this data
I can go to the insert tab
and choose Maps
let's select field map
there you go
you see we have a nice field map of the
United States
and here you can see the color scale
so it goes from light gray all the way
up to dark blue so the states that are
in dark blue let's say California made
the highest amount of sales you can also
validate it from the pivot table
similarly the lighter the color
the amount of sales were less for that
state
now let's give a chart Title Here
I'll
give a chart title as
sales by
States
and let's remove this Legend
now you can format this map so here you
can change colors and
let's see if I choose this one you can
see the color has changed
and you can see the California state
is shaded in dark which means it meet
the highest amount of sales
you can also
add data labels you can see it will show
the
sales values for each of the states
and if you want you can keep the legend
as well I'll just remove these two
all right
now similarly you can also create a
field map to see the profits by each
state so you can analyze which states
meet the highest amount of profit and
the state that meet the lowest amount of
profit so let's do that
I'll go to my data sheet
I'll
click on insert and select pivot table
let's click on OK
now first and foremost let's drag
country under rows
and then I'll choose State under rows
next
let's drag
The Profit column under values
so I have my
pivot table ready
let's go to the design Tab and remove
the subtotals
I'll select do not show subtotals if I
scroll down
okay I have my grand total now so let's
go to the design tab under Grant totals
we'll remove it
okay now let's just populate the United
States which is the country name for all
the rows
I'll right click on United States go to
field settings
click on layout and print I'll choose
select item labels in Tableau form and
select repeat item labels
let's click on OK
so I have my country name populated
throughout
let's
select the pivot table
I'll paste it somewhere here
and now let's go to the insert tab
I'll choose map let's select field map
there you go
now we have the
profits
for each of the states
let's first delete this
and editor chart title
which is
profit by
States
okay
let's close this
let's say
we'll use this one now
okay
let's edit the color of the chart title
I'll make it as white
and let's say
will
choose the color
as
set this one okay
now let me go ahead and remove the
Legend here
and just delete it all right
so we have our
field map ready which shows profit by
each state
now that we are done with our analysis
and creating our different pivot tables
and pivot charts let's build the final
dashboard
so let's create a new sheet here
okay
the first thing I need to do is I'll go
to the view Tab and I'll remove the grid
lines all right now let's go to the
insert Tab and here we have
text
let me choose text box
let's create a text box here
okay
now you can reduce the size actually
let's reduce it
okay
and you can move it to the top
all right let's pull this a little down
and this little till right
let's fill the text box color with
blue color
and
let's give the text as
sales
dashboard
and will
give a white color to the text and I'll
select my font
you can select any font you want
so I'll go with
let's say
Britannic bold
okay we have it here
and let's increase the size to 30
and we'll Center align it all right
now the next step is to
bring all our pivot charts
to this dashboard sheet so I'll first
copy my
pivot chart
and I'll paste it in sheet 8 let's paste
it here
and we can reduce the size
okay
now similarly let's do it for the
other charts as well I'll copy this
and let's paste it somewhere here
okay
now let me just reduce the size
and if you want you can reduce the
chart title font size as well let's make
it 11 okay and let's drag this a bit
all right
now let's
copy the pie chart
and let me paste it here
let's reduce the size of this pie chart
foreign
see we have our pie chart here
now
let me
take my line chart which shows the
quantity sold by
different subcategories of product I'll
copy it
and let me paste it
somewhere here
I'll close this
we need to reduce the size so that we
can fit in our other charts as well
okay let me reduce a bit more
all right now we are left with the two
maps that we created let's copy this and
let's paste it
here
I'll go to the right
let's reduce the size
similarly we'll do it for
sales by
profit map as well
let's copy this
and
paste it onto our dashboard
let's reduce the size first
and let's increase it
towards the bottom
so we have our
dashboard ready you can see the
different
pivot charts that we created
now let's add slicers and timelines to
this dashboard so that we can filter our
tables and the charts so I'll
click on this first chart which is our
line chart I'll go to the insert tab
here you can see under filters we have
slicers and timeline
first let me click on timeline and here
I'll choose my order date column
let me click on OK
all right let's drag this a bit here on
to the right
and I'll show you how you can use this
let's
first choose
years instead of months
and let me reduce the size a bit
okay
now another thing to do here is let me
right click
and I'll go to report connections here
I'll select
all my Pivot tables instead of just one
so that
any manipulation you do
in the order year it will reflect for
all the tables or the charts we have on
the dashboard I click on OK
now that we have seen how to add a
timeline
I'll reduce the subject
let's now add a few slicers
let's click on any of the charts
I go to insert click on slicer
now let's add a region slicer I'll click
on OK
and let's stick it to the right
we'll reduce the size of this region
slicer slices are nothing but filters
which have advanced filtering options
and
we can add
one more
filter
or a slicer let's say
we want to do this time on
the segment
so I'll go to slicer
I'll choose segment here and click on OK
so you can see I have my segment slicer
here let me just reduce the size
and
let's drag it here
at the bottom
all right
okay
now if you want to know the sales and
profit
for a particular year so you can choose
that particular year here on the
timeline suppose I want to know
the sales only for 2014 and 2015 so the
way to do is you can select one of the
years so I'll click on 2014
and now I'll drag this
to select 2015 as well
if I go to left
the figures that you see only reflect
the sales and the profit for 2014 and
15. similarly
if you Mark here
or let me just bring it
to the middle
suppose say I want to
have 2016 year included as well I can
just drag it to the right you can see
the charts will change
I'll just
remove the filter and place it here
similarly if you want to see the sales
and profit for
a particular region
you can do that too
for example let me just bring this
region slicer here
and let's say you want to know the sales
and profit only for the east region you
see here it shows only for the east
region
and suppose you want to see for east and
west region also
you can see it changes here
okay
let me just cancel this
now you might be wondering when we
selected the different regions only the
pie chart changed but the rest of the
charts were
the same now the reason was we did not
apply this slicer to all the pivot
tables so let me right click and go to
report connections
here I'll choose
the remaining pivot tables as well
and click on OK all right now let me
just bring this to the middle
and let's say we want to know the
seals and the profits and the quantities
sold for let's say south region
if I select this you can see it shows
only for the south region let's see you
also want to know for the central region
now we have selected both Central and
South you can see the variations in the
graph
and we cancel this
similarly we have or another slicer
which is the segment
I'll populate the slicer for
all the other pivot tables
let me choose all of them
and click on OK
I'll bring this
to the middle so that you can see the
variations in the graph let's say I want
to know the seals the unit sold and the
profit for home office segment so I'll
only select home office
you can see the variations here
now the slicers actually don't work for
the maps so you can't see any change
here
now suppose you want to know for the
corporate segment you can select
corporate or if you want to select for
multiple segments you can do that as
well
just cancel this
and let me place it here
all right now we are done with our demo
so if you want to get a copy of the data
set and the demo file that we are using
here in this video you can put your
email IDs in the comment section our
team will send you the files over email
we'll compare the two most popular job
roles in the field of Information
Technology that is business analyst
versus data analyst business analyst is
a professional who Bridges the gap
between the it and the business teams in
an organization they use data analytics
and modern Technologies to assess
processes and deliver data-driven
solutions they understand and solve a
business problem and validate business
requirements a business analyst
generates reports for executives and
stakeholders
a part of the business operation and
work closely with the technology team to
improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also assist in the
integration and testing of new Solutions
now let's talk about the job description
of a data analyst
with the rapid increase in data
generation today the term data analyst
has found its prominence
a data analyst collects processes and
performs analysis of large data sets
every business generates data in several
formats this data can be in the form of
customer information and feedback log
files transaction data marketing
research and so on it is the duty of a
data analyst to transform these business
data into valuable insights some of the
problems that can be addressed are how
to improve a business how to provide
good customer experience what would be
the ideal price for a new product how to
reduce Transportation costs and so on
data analysts deal with data handling
data modeling and Reporting with this
brief understanding of the job
description for a business analyst and a
data analyst let's now shift our Focus
towards the various responsibilities of
a business analyst
a business analyst identifies the
business goals understands the problems
faced by an organization and comes up
with a cost-effective solution to tackle
the issues they thoroughly understand
the requirements from the clients and
assign the right resources
BS communicate and work closely with the
development team to design the solution
for a problem they ensure that the
development team doesn't spend their
time understanding the stakeholders
requirements and often give iterative
feedback on the solution being developed
they check and validate if the project
is running fine with the help of user
acceptance testing they also verify if
the solution being worked on is in line
with the requirements and ensure that
the final product satisfies the user
expectations bases the functional and
non-functional requirements a business
analyst documents the project findings
and results they present the project
conclusions to the stakeholders and
clients along with delivering
maintenance reports and building
visualizations to make decisions now
let's take a look at the
responsibilities of a data analyst first
and foremost a data analyst must
identify and understand the
organization's goal and requirements
this helps to plan and streamline the
analysis process data analysts collect
data from various heterogeneous sources
they assist the available resources
comprehend the business problem and
gather the right data for analysis they
work closely with different team members
like programmers business analysts and
data scientists
data filtering and data wrangling are
vital jobs of a data analyst the data
collected is often noisy and it contains
missing values hence it is crucial to
clean the collected data and remove
invalid values to make it ready for
analysis they use a variety of
analytical statistical and business
intelligence tools to spot Trends and
patterns in complex data sets discover
hidden insights and prepare summary
reports for the leadership team
they also use programming languages for
data mining and data manipulation
now it's time for us to understand the
difference between a business analyst
and a data analyst based on the skill
set they possess
first let's look at the skills that can
help you become a ba a business analyst
should have a graduation degree in any
relevant field such as business
accounting Information Systems human
resources or engineering you can apply
for entry-level business analyst
positions or with professional
experience Excel is a powerful analytics
and reporting tool for working with data
Bas use Excel to perform various
calculations data analysis plan and
editorial calendar and calculate
customer discounts to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
BS use SQL to retrieve manipulate and
analyze data stored in relational
databases critical thinking skills are
important to understand customers
business needs it allows them to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those that
should be given a lower priority based
should find different ways to address
each challenge data visualization is a
key skill for Bas to build interactive
dashboards and reports to convey the
outcomes of a project
knowledge of Tableau power bi and click
view is required to make different types
of reports depending on the business
requirements business analysts should
have a good Hands-On programming
experience to solve complex tasks and
perform faster analysis of data
hence knowledge of programming languages
such as R and python is a prerequisite
finally they should have good
presentation skills they should also be
confident about their findings and
conclusions and communicate it in front
of the stakeholders and clients
let's Now understand the skills that a
data analyst should possess you must
have a bachelor's degree in any relevant
field or be a graduate in statistics
economics or science you're eligible to
become a data analyst being a fresher or
as an experienced professional you
should have domain knowledge in the
field you are working in once again
knowledge of excel is another basic
requirement for a data analyst data
analysts often work with structured data
so they should be proficient in writing
SQL queries using data manipulation and
data definition commands they should
know how to create stored procedures
another crucial skill for a data analyst
is to have hands-on experience with
programming languages such as python R
SAS and JavaScript you can analyze and
visualize large data sets and create
predictive models for making business
decisions data analysts create data
visualizations using libraries such as
matplotlib c-bond ggplot and plotly this
helps them to perform exploratory data
analysis knowledge of Tableau and power
bi is required to create different
business reports with the help of graphs
and charts data analysts should have
knowledge of machine learning algorithms
to build sophisticated models and make
future predictions
so they should know about linear
regression logistic regression support
Vector machines k-mean clustering and
other supervised and unsupervised
learning algorithms finally data
analysts should also possess good
communication and presentation skills
now let's discuss a salary structure for
both of these job roles
according to pay scale a business
analyst in the United States earns an
average salary of sixty nine thousand
dollars while in India you can earn
nearly 6 lakh rupees per annum now
talking about the salary of a data
analyst according to pay scale in the US
a data analyst earns an average salary
of sixty thousand seven hundred and ten
dollars per annum and in India you can
earn around 4 lakhs 24 000 rupees per
annum let's now move on and look at the
different companies hiring for business
analyst roles here we have Oracle the
search engine giant Google the American
MNC cognizant and e-commerce company
Amazon in addition to that we have
Ernest and Young technology giant IBM
Dell and Cisco hiring business analysts
talking about the companies hiring for
data analysts we have Twitter Google the
social media leader Facebook and Amazon
we also have the American Oil Company
shell the electric vehicle company Tesla
apple and the American Credit Reporting
Agency Equifax
now choosing the right field that is to
become a business analyst or a data
analyst could be a challenging task
the key points that you have to keep in
mind before making a decision is
first review your background and see
what qualifications you have check what
skills you possess and the domain
knowledge you have then gauge your
interest to see what suits you best
and finally consider your long-term
goals and see the job roles that will
help you grow in your career in the long
run now let me tell you how simply learn
can help you grow your career as a
business analyst and a data analyst
simplylearn offers a postgraduate
program in business analysis that is in
collaboration with Purdue University the
endorsed education provider is iiba some
of the skills that will be covered in
this course strategy analysis
wireframing solution evaluation
dashboarding data visualization agile
scrum methodology scrum artifacts
statistical analysis using Excel and SQL
database
some of the tools covered in this course
are Microsoft Excel Tableau power bi
jira postgres SQL plan box and others
some of the key features of this
business analysis program are you will
receive Purdue post graduate program
certification master classes from Purdue
faculty you can enroll in simply learns
job assist where you will get IM jobs
Pro membership for six months and obtain
35 iib APD cdus and 25 PMI pdus
you will get 170 Plus hours of Blended
learning along with Capstone projects in
three domains
to become a data analyst you can enroll
in the post-graduate program in data
analytics offered by simply learn
this program is in collaboration with
Peugeot University and IBM the skills
that will be covered as a part of the
course are statistical analysis using
Excel data analysis in Python and or
data visualization using Tableau and
power bi linear and logistic regression
modules clustering using k-means
supervised learning and others the tools
that you will learn are numpy pandas
sci-fi scikit-learn Excel and others
some of the key features of this course
are you will get Purdue postgraduate
program certification industry
recognized IBM certificates enrollment
and simply learns job assist and master
classes from Purdue faculty you have 180
Plus hours of Blended learning 14 plus
Hands-On projects on integrated labs and
Capstone projects in three domains
so please go ahead and enroll for these
programs if you want to grow your career
as a business analyst or a data analyst
business analyst interview questions
my name is Richard kirschner with the
simply learned team we'll go over some
beginner intermediate and advanced level
questions to expect in interviews when
you're looking at business analytics
let's start with the differentiation
between a risk and an issue
and this should be a very fundamental
question dealing with business because
in business they want to make money and
we really want to understand where the
split is on a lot of these things so
always ask yourself where is the bottom
dollar on this and what does this mean
risk is your potential and an issue is
something that's actually happening so
risk is a potential problem that can be
predicted risk me or may not happen in
the future a proactive response plan is
formulated and kept ready to mitigate
risks so these are things you plan for
and the issue refers to a risk that is
occurring or about to happen there's no
response plan in place to solve an issue
you can only respond reactively to an
issue what are the various tools a
business analyst works on
this is very
company specific and so when you start
looking for work you start going in for
interviews you should start really
asking yourself what are these companies
looking for that I'm interested in
clearly if you work with IBM you want to
have your tools that are Central to IBM
and the IBM setup same thing with Google
with you know just across the whole
field some of the more basic ones
obviously an Excel spreadsheet which
isn't on this list but your python your
SQL you should really know your SQL is
going to come up and no matter what
format you're in your Tableau your Azure
your balsamic all these are different
platforms there's a lot more out there
but you should be aware on which
platforms your proficiencies are on and
those also that you might not be
proficient on but you at least know what
they do and what their performance is so
you can answer questions and a lot of
companies will pay for you to be
certified if their platform isn't on
your list
what are the various stages of a
business project
and we look at project initiation
project planning project execution
project control and monitoring project
closure and it's really important to
understand any one of these in a little
bit more detail than just knowing the
list what is feasibility study a
feasibility study is a method of gauging
the success rate of proposed Business
Solution it enables business analysts to
discover new business opportunities
and really a lot of businesses when
they're looking at it for a business
analyst this is really what they want to
know what's the feasibility that is a
very central question that comes up in
most business plans what's the
feasibility of doing something and
getting it done what is business model
analysis business model analysis is a
technique that helps you analyze if a
business is financially economically and
socially viable or not
I know a number of contractors that this
is their sole career is to go in and
analyze ski resorts in Colorado to find
out whether it's going to make it this
year or not and what they need to do to
fix that so it's a very high-end job
Niche we really need to know your stuff
and understand what it means
what do you understand by requirement
differentiate between requirements and
needs we look at requirements a
requirement is a targeted solution that
is required to achieve the set business
objectives business requirements are
data used for business processes
needs needs are the high level
representation of the terms and the
result business needs include
identifying and comprehending the
businesses goals and articulating its
strategic direction and you can think of
needs are what do we need to succeed
requirements are well these are the
things we need to put into place this is
what's required to achieve a business
objective
suppose you have been given a list of
zip PIN codes
from different countries using those
codes find the city and the state names
using Excel
and so if you're given a list of zip
codes PIN codes of various cities from
the US and India here's how you can find
the city and the country names select
all the codes go to the data tab under
data types select geography click on the
insert data option choosing City from
the field list click on the insert data
option and select state from the field
list
really you do need to know your way
around Excel no matter what other
packages you're working with Excel is
such a base package in business analysis
so much people are given that back and
forth still it's still kind of a
Baseline
below our sales data that has
information on different items sold
across various regions and countries
what was the total revenue generated for
all the items in India
you can use the sum IF function to find
the total revenue generated from India
you see here equals some f and then of
course B2 to B 100 India L2 to l1001 and
that will view the sum you can also use
a filter option to filter the data only
for India and use subtotal by pressing
alt plus equals nice short hotkey to
remember there
create a highlight table to visualize a
revenue generated from offline and
online cells for different items across
the region using tableau
now not all companies use to have blue
but it is becoming a very highly used
tool because it's so easy to use you
drag the region onto columns drag the
cells Channel and item type Fields onto
rows select the total revenue column and
drag it on to color and label cards
select Square as the mark type
drag the total revenue field onto
columns drag the total profit column
onto rows Place item type column onto
colors under the size card place a total
profit drag the region column into the
filters card and select Asia
so one of the things about Tableau is it
looks real complicated but it's all drag
and drop and so you should know your way
around about doing some very simple drag
and drops for doing your query and
summation and below is the resulted plot
so let's look at some more questions but
let's jump to a little more intermediate
level
uh differentiate between software
development lifecycle and Project Life
Cycle
you're looking a little bit more
hierarchical towards the top of the list
software development life cycle helps
with the development of software
products it consists of a single
software across multiple phases here
phases include requirement Gathering
coding operations maintenance and
documentation
where the Project Life Cycle this
enables you to develop a new product in
the business Project Life Cycle consists
of multiple software and one customer
scenario phases here are idea generation
screening development testing and
Analysis how do you perform risk
management in your project so again
we're dealing with intermediate not just
how to pull tables across we're going to
start analyzing things and the risk
management is a technique wherein risks
are identified avoided reduced assessed
and mitigated
having the appropriate risk management
plan decreases losses and optimizes
decision making to enhance the
organization's performance how does risk
mitigation differ from risk avoidance
risk mitigation risk mitigation is a
plan to be executed when a risk occurs
when a risk occurs there might be a
business impact and the cost incurred is
high
risk avoidance whereas risk avoidance is
carried out to avoid the risk from
occurring meanwhile the business impact
here is zero and the cost is fully
eliminated and you can think about a
brick and mortar store and they have
shoplifting you want to mitigate as you
want to avoid as much shoplifting as you
can but you can only first people at the
door and have security so much before
you start losing customers and so when
you mitigate it you're going to have to
pay for your lost merchandise where you
avoid it you have your security cameras
and people watching to stop people from
stealing things
risk in this case can mean loss of money
spent badly spent on equipment
certifications there's all kinds of
areas where you want to mitigate and
avoid risk
what are project deliverables project
deliverables represent a collection of
measurable services and goods that are
to be delivered to the end user in the
project completion stage
this is so important we start talking
about any of our uh
when you sign a contract and you have
our online contracts cloud computing all
of that make sure you're very clear what
the deliverables are who owns it who is
the responsibility of the service and
the security around it those are all
very important questions to know
differentiate between the agile and
waterfall model two of our biggest or
most basic models used today the agile
model which is slowly taken over
especially in software the agile model
is adaptable to requirement changes and
has an incremental approach
in the agile model testing can be
performed in every phase
with the waterfall model the waterfall
model is referred as a structured
software development methodology changes
and requirements are difficult to
implement meanwhile in the waterfall
model testing is performed only in the
Final Phase
and you can look at this as a lot of the
software today has to be ready to change
quickly when the waterfall setup you're
not looking for fast changes you're
looking for a very solid it's going to
work no matter what kind of view this is
something that we can build it doesn't
have to make major changes but it better
work correctly
describe the different Analytics
analytical techniques like Moscow and
SWAT
Moscow analysis it is a prioritization
technique that highlights a
requirement's significance question like
is it a must-have or a should have could
the demand be made better would a
specific idea be useful in the future
are asked here
in the SWOT analysis it discovers the
strengths and weaknesses of a firm and
evaluates them as opportunities and
threats
SWOT analysis consists of strengths
weaknesses opportunities and threats and
you cannot kind of think of it as like
the SWAT team coming in
to you know you're worried about threats
here so we're talking about policing or
in Moscow really what is what can we get
out of this you know is is this do we
have to have it to succeed is it going
to be useful in the future so you're
looking more for a general value
attached to it list various components
of strategy analysis
for developing a strategic plan for an
organization the vital components are
vision
objectives Mission strategies action
plan what is benchmarking benchmarking
is a process of evaluating an
organization's measures like the quality
of policies programs Etc against the
standard criteria
it's so important to have that Baseline
of what are you measuring against the
Baseline might not even be a very good
one but you can't measure something
unless you have something to measure it
against it helps with the measuring the
performance of the company you can
recognize the areas of improvement in a
company and analyze how other companies
achieve other objectives
what is the best approach to work with
difficult stakeholders
a business analyst interacts with many
professionals during his work few of the
best approaches to take into
consideration while working with
difficult stakeholders are
before I even jump into this I have a
friend who is working with some very
high-end individuals who took their
private plane
and he was supposed to meet him at the
end location when he arrived they had
been in a fist fight while on their
private plane the stakeholders had so
much difficulty with some particular
aspect going on
so difficulties are going to arise
hopefully not at that level but things
happen
and of course you want to just assume
that work with anybody but you want to
listen patiently to the stakeholders
point of view
respond to them politely and
diplomatically have a one-on-one
discussion to make things more precise
comprehend their worries and be
transparent
make sure to continuously engage such
difficult stakeholders
and I'm going to highlight the last one
because if you're working with somebody
who's difficult and you just try to
ignore them
one of the things is that whatever
problems are arising they're just going
to explode
so that is so important not to ignore
the ignore somebody who's being
difficult but the rest of it is stay
focused stay focused on what you're
trying to accomplish uh be goal driven
this is a great time to be goal driven
not driven by emotion or the problems
that arise or how the person
communicates
name the different types of agile
methodologies
scrum I go get scrum certified important
thing to look into if you haven't
learn software development and extreme
programming XP
feature driven development FDD Crystal
kanban Dynamic systems development
method dsdm if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
other ones are out there is important to
at least know what we're talking about
when someone comes up and talks about
agile
describe the Gap analysis Gap analysis
refers to the analysis of differences
between the existing systems
functionalities and the targeted system
the Gap indicates the amount of work
required to get the intended result Gap
analysis is a comparison between the
current and proposed functionalities and
you can see here we put together an
action plan to go from the current state
to the desired state
how do you import text file data into Ms
Excel
and remember Excel is one of those
things that has been around forever and
even though it's like the bottom barrel
of a lot of uh analysis that we do most
of our data starts in an Excel
spreadsheet it you know or comma
separated variable file that you then
end up with an Excel spreadsheet given
below is the employee text file it has
information about name agent company
and here's how you can import this data
into Excel go to the data tab click on
get data drop down under from file
select text CSV select where the text
file is located in your system and click
on import click on low data imported
into Excel
he had been given sales data that has
information on the cell of different
items across the world below is the data
create a pivot table to analyze the
profit of all the items in each region
now remember our pivot table is a table
of Statistics that summarizes the data
of a more extensive table so it takes a
full data sheet and we're just going to
bring we're going to focus zoom in on
something that's what the pro the pivot
table means
if we want to go ahead and do this what
we do is go ahead and select a cell in
the table go to insert and click on
pivot table
in the create pivot table box choose
existing worksheet to place your pivot
table drag region and item type onto
rows drag total profit onto values sort
the sum of the total profit column using
the sales table find the percentage
contribution of Cosmetics to the total
revenue and total profit
create a pivot table by dragging item
type onto rows select the revenue and
profit column under values right click
on the revenue value under show value as
select percentage of grand total right
click on a profit value under show value
as choose percentage of grand total and
you can see here when we do that we end
up with Cosmetics made a 14.03
contributions to the total revenue and
an 18.94 contribution to the total
profit how do you create a dual axis
chart in Tableau drag the order data
onto columns and convert it into
continuous year drag total revenue onto
rows and total profit to the right
corner of the view until you see the
light green rectangle
synchronize the right Axis by right
clicking on the profit axes under the
marks card change sum total revenue to
bar and some total profit to line and
adjust the size and color
they're lots of fun to play with as you
start getting into these
using the sales data Create A View to
show the total units sold and the profit
generated from each item which item sold
the police and has the least profit
so we'll go ahead and load an Excel file
data in Tableau desktop
drag units sold onto columns and item
type column onto rows place the total
profit column under calor and choose the
desired color palette sort the unit sold
axes in descending order
you can see here it produces a very
quick
um bug figure shows the fruit sold and
the least and had the least amount of
profit
create a map to show the units sold and
the profit generated from different
Middle East and North Africa items drag
country onto the detail card place a
total profit column under size drag
units sold under color
in the filters card drag the region
column and select Middle East and North
Africa
Bahrain had the maximum number of units
sold at the same time Iran made the full
amount of profit
create a visualization to analyze the
total revenue and the units sold for
clothes meat and baby food across
different regions in 2006 and 2017.
drag the units sold filled on the
columns drag the region and item type
Fields onto rows under the cooler card
place a total revenue column drag item
type onto filters and choose clothes
meat and baby food drag the ordered date
column onto filters and select 2016 and
2017. meet had the highest unit sold
that made the maximum profit now if any
of these Tableau it's good if you have
your own hands on for this
um so that's an important thing to note
we kind of zoomed in on Tableau again
there's a lot of other companies out
there using a lot of other packages so
if you're not familiar with Tableau but
you're able to do this in another
package uh that's a good thing so at
least you know what we're talking about
and you've had that Hands-On
let's go ahead and jump to some advanced
level questions
what is requirement prioritization name
the different techniques used for it
requirements prioritization focuses on
allocating requirements depending on the
business
urgencies this is essential for the
project to run well requirement
prioritization enables various teams to
understand what is important and work in
sync with the business needs
there are several techniques used for
requirement prioritization we had Moscow
Technique we mentioned that earlier the
requirements are grouped based on must
mandatory should high priority could not
necessary but preferred and would
suggested for the future
ranking method here you give each
requirement a distinct numerical value
based on its importance
of course this is at 100
um
oh well here's kind of similar to
ranking is the 100 method multiple
stakeholders get a no uh notional 100 to
distribute among the requirements so the
100 method is pretty similar to what the
ranking method is
top 10 requirements in this approach
from a large set the stakeholders simply
picked their top 10 requirements
this is very popular there's a lot of
helpbooks out there about getting things
done they say write everything that you
want to accomplish put them on three by
five cards and narrow it down to five do
those five because once you've conquered
those five then you can move on to the
next ones
name the critical agile metrics that
should be considered by a business
analyst
Sprint burn down so the Sprint burn down
is the chart we use when you're tracking
usually it's in scrums where that
usually comes from the scrum setup but
it's a chart of the work to be completed
and what's still going on
you have your work category allocation
the velocity
the cumulative flow diagram defect
removal awareness time coverage defect
resolution time explain bpmn
MN business process model and notation
Gateway controls the flow of interaction
and sequence of processes it is a
flowchart technique Which models the
end-to-end business process step the
four essential elements of bpmn are flow
objects events activities gateways
connecting objects sequence messages
associations swim Lanes pool or Lane
artifacts data object group annotation
list the
techniques the elicitation process is
about Gathering requirements from users
and stakeholders listed below are a few
techniques that are used to collaborate
with users or clients
interviews
I don't know how many times I've been on
the phone calling uh competition
potential clients to ask questions uh so
one of the elicitation techniques is to
ask questions if you're going to call
clients to ask questions in a lot of
terms also turn into additional sales
document analysis Focus Group
prototyping
brainstorming my favorite brainstorming
all these are important I just kind of
highlight a few of them that I tend to
get stuck in observations and workshops
again workshops are a great sales
technique also so as you're doing your
business analysis and you're bringing
people into a workshop and do
observations in the workshop and working
specifically with these people they turn
into potential business growth I tell
you what if you're a shareholder and
someone's doing a business analysis and
they turn around and generate a thirty
thousand dollar sale for your company
they're in you know you've already
earned your you've already earned your
pay and you're doing what you like which
is business analysis
interface analysis questionnaire and
Survey questionnaire survey is my least
favorite but they are the most popular
because they're the easiest to pump out
listed documents needed by a business
analyst
initiation document project Vision
document
use cases system requirements
specifications document
business requirement document
requirements traceability Matrix
functional requirement document use case
specifications document gap analyst
document describe how you would approach
a project
here's a basic project approach outline
which you can use with respect to
different situations
identifying the project goal formulating
the work plan defining the requirements
collaborating with other teams tracking
the project documenting the progress
and really when you start
designing your project approach
encompassing all the things listed in
here is so important with the
shareholders if you I mean it's great if
you can identify your project goal
that's probably the most important thing
because if you don't have a goal you
might as well walk away
but if you don't have the rest well how
are you formulating the work plan
defining the requirements collaborating
with other teams that is such a big step
because we're going from everything
being on paper and trying to figure out
what you're going to do to actually
doing it and then tracking and finally
documenting very important for the
shareholders and what goes back to the
top
differentiate an alternate flow and
exception flow in a use case diagram
from a basic flow
basic flow represents the operation of
activities as required by the company
in a use case alternate flow as the name
suggests is an alternate solution used
in a system failure case different steps
are used to complete the goals of a use
cases
exception flow refers to the various
steps executed in case of errors this
does not lead to achieving the acquired
goal of a use case
critical aspects of creating analytical
reporting analytical reporting is a type
of business reporting which provides
data analysis information and
recommendations it enables people to use
data to make decisions
to create analytical reporting the
following points should be kept in mind
comprehend business analysis display
your analysis skills think critically
and I'm going to throw in here the term
from Big Data map and reduce
really when we're doing a business
analysis
you don't want to give them a massive
amount of information you want to reduce
it down to something that they can see
in a single graph a very simple set of
notes and you need to think critically
you need to really make it what is it
that the shareholders want that's going
to make them understand why this is
important to the business and what does
a business get out of it what is kanban
and helps agile teams in visually
managing work through processes it works
as a scheduling system in agile just in
time production the kanban methodology
is all about real-time communication of
capacity and full transparency of work
the kanban board describes a current
development status
of course when you're working with
kanban you've got to be very careful
about
inspiring versus coaching versus
micromanaging
it really can end up in a micromanage
being set up where you want to you want
to watch out for that but you also need
to track everything
a basic kanban board has three-step
workflow it has the to do in progress
and done however depending on a team
size structure and objectives the
workflow can be mapped to meet any
particular team's unique process
differences between BRD and SRS
BRD business requirements documents is a
high level functional specification of
software BRD is a formal document to
describe the requirement provided by the
client business analysts create this
post their interaction with the clients
SRS system requirement specification is
a high-level functional and Technical
specification of software SRS describes
the software's functions and
non-functional requirements that are
needed to be developed whereas SRS is
created by the systems architects
what is Pareto analysis the Pareto
analysis helps in crucial decision
making and helps in prioritizing
decisions identifying the most relevant
and the least decision concerning the
overall goal
is also known as the 80 20 rule as per
this rule 82 of the projects benefit
arises from 20 percent of the work vice
versa eighty percent of the case problem
can be due to 20 percent of the causes
differentiate between the V model and
the fish model
we talk about the V model it is an sdlc
model where the execution of processes
happens sequentially in a V shape
at every stage the same person reviews
but other testers will do software
testing in the last step
V model consumes less time and cost
the fish model is similar to The V model
but with more multiple verification
teams
every stage is tested by another team
for completeness and correctness the
fish model is compared to the very
costly and time consuming
which makes sense because if you have
multiple tests on each stage from
multiple teams they have to all be spun
up on it and so you're literally more
than doubling the work because you also
have to track all that
given the sales data create a chart to
show each Region's country that made the
highest revenue create a pivot table by
dragging the region and Country onto
rows place a total revenue column under
values right click on the country value
select the filter options and choose top
ten choose top one as shown above and
click on OK
and you can see here is the pivot table
that you will get
using the cells data find all the
countries where the total units of
fruits sold offline were less than three
thousand you need to use an advanced
filter option in Microsoft Excel to
solve this problem
below is a critical based on the
question we have go to the data tab
select Advanced filter option choose
copy to another location give your
criteria range and the copy to location
we'll click on OK
here's a final result as we can see
below let's create a pivot table to find
which countries from each region made
the lowest amount profit create a pivot
table by dragging the region and the
country into rows Place The Profit
column under values right click on any
country value select the filter option
and choose top 10 choose bottom one and
click on OK
let's create a filled map to analyze the
total revenue and profit generated from
beverages in North America using Tableau
drag country under detail card place a
total revenue column under the text drag
total profit under color and the filters
card drag the region column and select
North America in the filters card drag
the item type column and select
beverages
and you can see from the below map you
can see that Greenland and the maximum
revenue and profit generated from
beverages in North America
who knew
using tablu how will you display the top
five and bottom five items based on
profit
drag the item type filled under rows and
total profit onto columns right click on
the item type column to create a set
give a name to the set and select the
top tab to choose the top five items by
sum total profit
create a set for the bottom five items
by some total profit select both the
sets right click to create a combined
set give a name to the set and choose
all members in both sets drag the new
set on the filters and the total profit
onto color
the above graph depicts the Cosmetics
made the highest profit while fruits
made the lowest and really when we're
talking about tools like tableau
or if you're targeting companies working
in r or you're targeting companies
working in Python you should be able to
quickly do these kind of displays in any
of those packages that you're focused on
Tableau is one of the biggest ones out
there right now because it is paid for
service but it's also very robust and
easy to use and uses less programming on
the back end so just a quick side note
on there roll your sleeves up if you if
this does not look right to you you're
not able to get through some of these
things make sure you are if that's what
you're targeting in a company for an
interview in this video we will learn
everything from Basics to Advanced in
Excel I'll experience instructor Aja
will help you learn in detail you will
start off by taking a tour to welcome to
excel where you will learn the basics
then you will understand the various
crucial functions available in Excel
such as vlookup hlookup sumifs counters
if error and others
you will learn how to sort and filter
data in Excel then we'll focus on
conditional formatting and data
validation
moving further you will get an idea how
to create po tables in po charts in
Excel
and finally you will see how to use the
data analysis tool pack to perform
various data analysis operations such as
regression sampling descriptive
statistics and much more over to Ajay
now hi everyone welcome to this tutorial
on Microsoft Excel so we will learn
about functions and formulas we will
learn about conditional formatting data
validation pivot chart and pivot table
now let's look at the scenario here so
one day in a startup
One Professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague response
well we can make use of Microsoft Excel
to do this job
the question is will excel be able to
cater to their business needs
now
the colleague response well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question says let's go ahead with
Excel and let's train our employees in
Excel
and the suggestion is welcomed which
would make the job easier for them and
they would basically decide on using
Excel so they decide on taking a
training right away and basically
starting to learn Excel
now
before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use Excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so Excel proves to be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days various
features in Excel like searching sorting
filtering makes it easier for you to
play with the data and Excel also allows
you to beautify your data and present it
in the form of charts tables and data
bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and Analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
Excel also provides good security for
your data Excel files have the feature
of password protection this way your
information can be safe
now when we talk about what is Excel and
how it can be used
so Excel or you might have heard a
spreadsheet can be basically used for a
lot of different tasks than just storing
the information in so-called tabular
format
now Microsoft Excel is an application
that is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in Excel and
before we do that we can also quickly
take a small tour to understand how to
work with Excel now to do that what we
can do is we can type in in our search
say for example Excel and just select
your Excel app which is installed and
here you see you have lot of options
which says take a tour drop down list
get started with formulas make your
pivot table going forward with pie
charts and much more so we can click on
this one which says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to Excel and if you
have always wanted to be better at Excel
you have this which can help you so
let's click on Create and that takes us
to the store window now that says
instructions for screen readers which
basically talks about 10 different steps
in which we can learn Excel and using
the spreadsheet app so there are more
than 11 sheets which we see here at the
bottom end and each one gives us a
simple example which we can work on so
for example if I click on ADD now that
takes me to this page which says how do
we add numbers now you might be provided
data which we can upload by loading a
file from our machine or getting data
from a web Source or even connecting to
a database so there are various options
which we will see in some time so here
we have an option which is called Data
you can click on this one and this
basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from SQL
Server from analysis services from odata
data feed you can get in from XML from
data connection Wizard or also from
Microsoft query you can be running in
different queries here which shows up in
the option which says new query there
are connections which you can use and
that basically will display all the
connections for this particular workbook
which we do not have as of now but we
can create them but let's look at simple
examples now you can follow these
instructions here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here and what you could do is either you
can type in the formula that is from
which row to which row you would want to
add the data so for example I could just
do a sum here and that shows up all the
different functions which are available
then we can open up a parenthesis and we
can say I would be interested in
totaling the amount
from
column D and I would select for example
D4 so I could be doing this and then I
could say D4
onwards till d 7 so that's the data
which I'm interested in you can close
your parenthesis and hit enter and that
gives you the total there is also a
shortcut for this which you can always
do is we can first delete this and you
can just place your cursor here and just
use your alt and equals that
automatically selects the numericals
which we can anytime expand or basically
collapse so I will basically select this
which says this function needs two
numbers which is number one and number
two and then you can hit on enter and
that gives you the total so similarly we
can be getting in the data here by
selecting all the fields so here it also
says that you can use a shortcut now
what we can also do is we can add
numbers over 50 by selecting the yellow
cell here and then giving a condition
such as so I can basically use something
like sum if and then open a parenthesis
I can select I would be interested in
this row and then I can even drag and
drop
till here so that tells me the 11 to the
15 you can then put in a comma here and
you can give your condition say for
example we would say I would be
interested in numbers only above 50 and
we can select this
close your codes and then just close
your paranthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total is hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here I could select this now
there is also an option I can click on
home and I can go for something like
Auto sum so that's one more way of doing
it which anyway says sum is alt plus
equals so it automatically adds up your
values and I can try doing a auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then I can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
sum if formula here but add amounts that
are less than 100 and the result should
be 160. so what we can do is we can
basically select all the numbers which
are lesser than 100 so the way we did
earlier here that can be always a
shortcut so you can always for example
if you would want to avoid typing in the
formula you can always copy it from here
and then just hit on enter so you are
back into this cell and then I can
basically go here and paste the number
and then as per the requirement we are
required to select anything which is
lesser than 100 so what I could do is I
could select here I could say let's say
G and then I can change this value to
g15 and that's one more way now we see
our selected rows have been changed so I
can hit on enter and I can check what is
the result so we would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so I will have to also change
this one to a lesser sign and that
basically gives me the total which is
160. so that's how you can simply add
numbers you can use autosum you can type
in the formula you can select the fields
or you can just place your cursor where
you would be looking for a sum and then
you can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at
some easy options of filling your cells
or automatically populating the values
in your cells within your Excel sheet
now here we have an option which says
100 now we can click on this and that
basically says it is making a sum of
column C4 to D4 so if I click on this
one I can check that this is row number
four which shows up here and I also know
this is column C I also have D so this
equals is basically giving me a sum of
C4 to D4 now what we can do is we can
always place our cursor here at the
right corner and then we can just drag
and drop and this basically gives me a
total of all the numbers for all
different rows so this is one shortcut
which we can do to get the total Excel
will automatically give the totals which
we call as filling down now what we can
do is in the same way if we would want
to get the totals here we can first
check what is this 200 and this tells me
this C11 to c14 total so it is totaling
the rows from C11 so column C and 11th
row till 14th row and that's the sum now
what I can also do is I can similarly
like above we can do a filling right
which basically means bringing your
cursor here and then just dragging and
dropping it all the way where you would
need the totals and this basically gives
me the total there is one more quick way
to check if this is right so the easiest
option would be to select this cell now
what I can also do is I can just select
all of these fields by just highlighting
and selecting all the fields once it is
selected Press On Ctrl R and that gives
you the total now if we would be doing
this stop down then I could select all
these rows for this particular column
and then I could do a control D so
that's your filling down and this one
was failing right so this is an easier
option of doing a fill when you would
want to have the formula applied to
every row as it occurs in the first row
or the last row we could test this by
for example selecting these fields I
could delete them and I have here which
says 130 I could just place my cursor
here and I could drag it all the way up
and that should also do the same magic
which we were seeing from top down so
this is a simple way wherein you can
fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate or move your computation to
all the cells
let's look at the split option which
basically helps us in splitting the data
when we have some kind of pattern or
when we have some kind of delimiters in
our data in say one particular column
and we would want to derive the values
out of it so we can always use the
splitting option now the easiest option
would be so for example we have our
email column which has the email IDs in
which we can clearly see has a first
name dot last name now I see that there
is a last name Smith filled up here
first name is empty so what I can also
do is I can just type in say Nancy here
now that's the first name I can again
start typing the second name and as soon
as you do that you would see a faded
list of numbers and that's your clue to
hit enter and once you do that you would
see all the first names have been filled
in here if you would want to maintain
the case sensitiveness you can just go
ahead and delete these and let's type in
as it occurs so let's say Nancy as the
first name go down to the next cell and
just type in Andy and there is your
grade list so just hit on enter and that
basically fills up your first name what
we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now I can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking Ctrl Z and that's basically
gone what I can also do is I can select
a particular field and then I can go
into home option and under home you have
an option here which says fill so you
can select this and then you can do a
Flash Fill which is what we are doing
here so click on Flash Fill and that
automatically fills up the values so in
this way you can work within your
spreadsheet and you can be filling up
the values where a delimiter by default
is understood and we can split the data
now however sometimes you might have
some data which has a different kind of
delimiter and there is again a smarter
way of splitting your data so you can
always scroll down here and that says
splitting a column based on delimiters
so we have some values in the data
column and these values in each row are
separated by comma so
select this your data is already
selected text to columns delimited comma
I selected and now click on next so it
basically says what is the destination
let's select this one
and I can choose what would you want to
have so that shows me this would be my
GitHub preview now I can basically
select this one I can say finish and say
okay and now if you see our data has
been placed in in the columns
appropriately so this is how you can
split your data based on a delimiter and
then organize your data in a better way
now there are some Advanced options
which we can learn later but this
basically tells about using a formula so
this is something if say if we have some
name in one cell and if you would want
to split it into first name your helper
column your middle name last name so
that can also be done using formulas and
this basically tells how would you
extract characters from your left cell
and how would you place them in your
right cell so you can try this activity
which is a little more of advanced
option the benefit is that you can
always use this
wherein if you do some kind of
transformation using your formulas if
your original data gets updated then the
split data will also get updated and
that's the benefit of using formulas
where you can place values from one cell
into multiple cells based on execution
of your details in the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
in your X and Y axis or as I would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become your rows
so what we can do is the simplest way is
you can select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and I would say two rows now I
can select all of these and then I can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a control alt V that's a
shortcut what you can also do is once
you have selected all your Fields you
can just copy them so just do a Ctrl C
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home you have the paste option and here
you can go for paste special and once
you do that you need to select the
transpose option over here and click on
OK and now you will see that the columns
and the rows have been transposed so
your row name was item and that has
become the column heading you had row
name as a mount and that has become the
column heading and all your values have
been transposed in this particular
format now there is another way of doing
that and again that's using your
formulas so what you can do is you can
transpose with a formula also and that
basically works when you have similar
kind of data so this has six columns and
basically two rows so you can basically
do this so you can select this and
earlier we were doing a copy but now
what we would want to do is we would
want to just look at the row numbers
which tells me it is c33 c34 and it
starts with c and ends in with your H
column so what we can do is we know that
we have six columns and two rows so
transposing that would actually give me
two columns and six rows so what we can
do is we can select two columns and six
rows in our Excel sheet I can then
basically start typing in the message or
I can just go to the address bar and
here I can say
transpose
let's go for c33
h34 it basically selects my data and now
I can just do a control shift and enter
and now if you see all the values have
been populated now you can just place
your cursor in one of the cells but if
you see the address bar the formula
Remains the Same this is because this is
an array formula so we can read more
about an array formula here it's
basically something which performs
calculations and on more than one cell
in an array and in the example here the
array is the original data that is c33
to h34 so your transpose is just
changing the horizontal orientation to
the vertical orientation so this is a
very simple way in which you can
basically use the excels capability to
transpose your data and convert your
rows into columns and columns into rows
apart from working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data sorting the data or basically
splitting your data transposing your
data one of the other requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you're working on
huge data and you would want to sort it
in a particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular field or if that field was or
if the cell was highlighted with a
particular color sorting the data so
let's look at how Excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here so let's check that
so if we're going to sort and filter and
say this is the data I have say for
example I would want to sort the values
in the department column alphabetically
so what I can do is I can select
Department column and I'm already in the
Home tab I can straight away go here
which says sort and filter here I can
then say sort A to Z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column and once once I do
this you would see the data has been
sorted but it's not just this data we
can just do a control Z and check what
are the values we have so here we have
meet which is beef and ninety thousand
hundred ten thousand the values then you
have Bakery which should ideally be the
first row if we sort it in an
alphabetical order which goes with
Bakery as desserts you have the values
so we can check this again so select
department and then just do a sort and
filter and let's say sort A to Z and if
you see the data has changed but it's
not just in changing your First Column
but then it has taken care of all the
data however the data has been sorted
based on the department column so you
have Bakery which aligns with deserts
which has the values and now we have all
the data which has been filtered now
what we can also do is we can sort
December's amounts from largest to
smallest so what we can do is we can
basically click any cell in the December
column let's say 20 000 and then what I
can do is I can go into sort filter and
then I can say sort largest to smallest
so if you see Bakery breads is the row
which has the smallest data or maybe you
have Delhi sandwiches so that one looks
also smaller so let's do a larger to
smallest and if I do this you would see
the values have been shifted now so it
is no more based on the department
column because now the data is being
sorted based on the values in the
December column and you see Bakery which
was alphabetically the first one has
become second last
so either you can sort the data based on
a department column which goes based on
the values these are all string values
or words so it sorts alphabetically if
you have numbers might be you can give
some values and you can sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select if you would
want to select the data so I could do a
custom sort and then I could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting what is the Sorting
needs to be done is it cell values is it
cell color font color conditional
formatting and then you can also choose
the order so that's one more way to do
that now if you scroll down that also
shows how you can sort by date or a
color so for example if you would want
to sort based on the expense date so
there are different options so what I
can do is I can select this date field I
can just do a right click I can go into
sort and then I can choose I would want
to sort oldest to newest so since I
selected the date field it basically has
sorted all the data data and it has
taken the expense date into
consideration now there are these
filters which you see on the row
headings we could have also used those
so I could have selected this and that
basically says or mentions which are the
dates I would be interested in looking
at I also have sort by color here I can
do a sort oldest or newest or newest to
oldest so I could also use these filters
which have been applied here now we have
the data which is in color so if I would
want to basically select the color
columns or color cells I could select
this I can basically do a right click
here and when I go into sort I could
choose put selected color or cell color
on the top and that basically will make
sure that my data is sorted and it has
also sorted that in a descending order
so in this way you can sort or basically
filter your data what we can also do is
we can add filters so sometimes we can
go for formulas which we would want to
use what we can also do is we can
basically select the filter which has
been applied here now how does the
filter come in there so if I would
select a particular row I could select a
particular row and then I could decide
if I would want to just add a filter to
this one and that's how the filter has
come in so we have the filter what we
can do is we can basically click on this
drop down and then you have something
like number filters so we can always go
here we can basically choose one of
these so we can basically choose above
average so I could select this and then
basically it shows me the values we
could also delete the filter by clicking
on this one and we could say well I'm
not interested in this filter anymore
so I could clear the filter and that
shows me all the values or I could say
that let's click on some other field for
example food I can go in here I can go
into number filters and then I could say
well I'm interested in values which are
below average above average might be
greater than and then I can choose what
is the value so for example if we say I
am interested in food which is greater
than 25 dollars I could give a value
here I could say okay and now I have
applied the filter similarly you can
select this and then you can just clear
your filter and your data is back so
remember no data is lost
it is just hidden or basically based on
the filter not shown so that's good
enough for us and in this way you can
sort and filter the data so for more
details obviously in all the sheets you
have the links which point to more
information on the web and you can
always refer to these so this is simple
way in which you can sort and filter any
amount of data which has been stored
within your Excel within a particular
sheet now that we have learned about add
fill split transpose sorting and
filtering it will also be good to learn
how to work with tables or basically
converting your data into a tabular
format and then doing some easy
computations so click on this tables
option here now here we see there is
some data which is in five columns and N
number of rows so I can basically select
this data and then what I can do is I
can insert choose the table option and
then it says my table as headers and
we'll be okay with that I'll say okay
and now if you see this is the table
created it basically has different
filters which we have learned earlier
how to use and this is basically my
table which is a collection of cells
which has some special features so we
can easily add rows to this table we can
add columns to this table and we can
even do some calculations so for example
here I can click on this one I can
basically enter some field and then I
can hit on enter and we see that this
row has been inserted wherein we can
easily fill in values for example I
would say chocolates
I could give some value here so is 25
000 might be 35
000 and then basically I can given some
values here now what you can also do is
you can continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this
option here in the top bottom right
corner you can just drag it towards the
right and that basically has
automatically created columns for my
next months wherein I can feed in the
data so this is a simpler way wherein
you can keep adding more rows and
columns to your data if that has been
converted in a tabular format now let me
just do a control Z that basically
deletes the columns again Ctrl Z deletes
the last row which we added and I can
stop here or I can even remove my values
by doing multiple control Z and removing
my rows so this is how I converted my
data into a table and then I can easily
work on this what I can also do is I can
do some calculations so what we can do
we have a table here we have a total
field and what we can do is we can just
select one cell here now as we have
learned earlier we can do a alt and then
equals and that basically says what is
this doing so it says it is calculating
the sum of the last three months and if
that's what you would want to do just
hit on enter and it has automatically
calculated the totals for all your rows
for these three columns so the sum
formula is getting filled up now I can
select any particular cell and I can
look in my address bar so it has already
given me the formula where it has
started calculating the sum from the
October column till the December column
and has given me the calculated values
of the columns what we can also do is we
can get total rows in the table now
that's a simpler option so what we can
do is we can select any l in this
particular table
and then we see that there is a table
tools design option showing up here now
I can select this and then it says well
let's get a total row so let's select
this and it automatically populates the
total here and if you would want the
average then we could select this and
from the drop down I can select what I'm
interested in so for example I would
want the average values and not the
total I could just select this and that
gives me the average of these values so
we can always do simpler computations
here by converting our data into table
format let's learn about one more
efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here now say for example
you have this data which has the values
in the food column and department is
empty and say for example you would want
to enter the values in Department
however you would want to select the
department should either have produce or
meet and bakery and these are the only
three options which should be available
for any user to fill in the values how
do we do that so we can basically create
a table by pressing Ctrl D so what I can
do is under my department
here I can select one of the cells and
then I can do a control T that basically
converts this into a table I can say
okay and my table is created now what I
can do is once this part is done
we can select all the blank Fields here
where we would want this drop down to be
applicable now under your data tab you
can go in and select data validation and
this has an option called Data
validation click on this which basically
says allow any value so here I will
select I would want to give a list of
values and then I can type in my values
here which I can say produce
say for example meet and then say Bakery
now these are the values so we can click
on okay
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to Apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so I can go into every cell and
then I can basically choose what is the
department which handles this and then
basically I can select one of these from
the drop down so this is an easier
option of creating your drop down and
then feeding in the values from the set
of values which you have defined here on
the right so this is a simple example of
using your drop downs working with your
tables working with your sort and filter
transpose split filling up your data
adding in some data here and similarly
you can use Excel for more than one use
case using its inbuilt features to
easily work with your data let's see how
we can import data or bring in data into
our Excel from your local machine or
from an external web source so what we
can do is we can open up a blank Excel
sheet and say for example you have been
provided a text file or a CSV file and
you would want to import that data into
your Excel sheet that can be easily done
so right now I've opened an Excel sheet
now I can click on data and here I have
an option which says existing
connections from other data sources so
or you can click on connections if you
have already created some so we can
click on from other sources so this is
one option where you can connect to your
different data sources and you can get
the data from one of these what we can
also do is I can click on connections
now it says there is none I can click on
ADD it says well show the connections
where connection files or Network
connection files on this computer so I
can say let's get some files from this
computer now if that does not show up
something so say browse for more and
that basically shows you different
options so let's basically select a
folder where I have some data sets I'll
click in here and this is basically a
folder where I have some data sets now
let me select this particular file and I
know it is a CSV file so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a DOT CSV file which is what we
are interested in so I'll take this file
I'll say open now this basically shows
me the text import wizard option which
says is the file delimited I'll say yes
click on next so I will select comma as
my delimiter I can say text qualifier is
none
now this is my data so my data preview
is already showing me the data is what
is the data in the CSV file you can
click on next and then you have an
option which says data format is General
you can go for date format you can go
for advanced options so I'll just say
finish
and basically now this has been created
here so we basically have this and now I
can click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data which we have here the
connection which we have created say
open and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on OK and now this
data is automatically inserted in my
Excel file I can basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what I
can do is I can go into my GitHub and
let's say I would be interested in this
CSV file so I can select this and this
is my GitHub path a path on web so I can
click on raw and that basically gives me
the raw path where this particular file
is now you can select this copy this
particular path and here you can come
back to your Excel sheet we would be
interested in getting the data from web
might be from a text file where we will
have to specify the delimiters or let's
go to web and here I can given the web
path from where I would be interested in
getting the file let's give the GitHub
path which is publicly available and
then click on import now once you click
on import it tells me that two Fields
data and value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web and put in here it
says existing worksheet so we had
already created a new worksheet so let's
click on OK and now you have the data
coming in but then this basically shows
me in one particular field so what we
can also do is we can just do a control
a that selects all my columns here and
that's my data so we can then basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next we
can select comma and let the text
qualifier be codes it shows me data
preview click on next so you have the
general format it shows the destination
that's the column click on finish and
now your data has been split and you
have the data which you have imported
from web so this is the data which is
coming in from web this is the data
which came in from my local machine and
similarly we can even create connection
with an existing database so I can
basically click on connections if I
would want to do that so I have an
option called connection here and it
says where the selected connections are
used I can basically click on ADD I can
basically choose if I would want to get
the files from Network or from computer
like we did earlier I can click on
browse for more which should show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new SQL Server Connection you can
connect to a new data source coming in
from different place you could basically
choose what kind of connection would you
want so these are all the different
options which we can go for and we can
basically connect to a database for
example if I have some database and say
for example access database
I can see if there are some files with
that particular database and I can
import it so similarly we can also uh
click in here which says new query and
that also gives you an option of getting
the data from your files from all these
folders from databases so you can
basically click here and then you can
import data from a mySQL database
provided that is set up on your local
machine or on a particular server you
can go from cloud you can get it from
online services you can get it from
other sources which says from web from
your Hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor you can get the
data from different sources and then you
can bring it into your Excel so in this
way you can get your data from different
sources into your Excel into your
spreadsheet and then you can continue
working on those data sets
we have already learned some basic
operations which you can do in Excel and
let's Implement our knowledge by working
on this particular data which is coming
in from housing data set now here if we
see some fields we have agent date
listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been sorted
in newest to oldest order of date listed
so how do we
arrive at this so what I can do is I can
just click on data listed and then I can
either go in here I can select sort I
can get into custom sort and then I can
choose the column based on which I would
want to sort the data so I would look
for the newest data to the oldest data
that means that would mean a descending
order of dates or you could say the
oldest state or the earliest month will
be towards the lower side of your sheet
so here we can select date listed now I
can say let it sort based on Cell values
and the order what we have here so we
have newest to oldest so let's select
this I can say OK and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see an earlier month hour and
earlier month than that in the state
listed so we have sorted our data into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your date column so the result shows
up here now what we can also do is we
can have different questions which we
would want to answer so for example I
would want to sort the data in ascending
order of area and descending order of
agent name how do we do that so let's
look into this so this is here I already
have the result here and how did I get
this so I'm looking for ascending order
of area and descending order of agent
name so we can start with any particular
column that does not matter so for
example if I look into this Excel sheet
I have my agent name select this which
we want in a descending order so we
could either do a sort and then go for
descending sort Z to A we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it or I could just say
sort Z to A and then it has arranged the
data based on the agent column being in
descending order now I can go into area
and then I can again do a sort and I
wanted my area column to be used for
sorting the data and ascending to
descending and that basically not only
changes the order of this particular
column but for my complete data so let's
do that and now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so we can see
how many values we have here and the
area values which we see and this is how
you get your result so I'll just do a
control Z and again and I'm back to my
original data and this is the sorted
result which we are seeing at similarly
we can answer other questions for
example sort the data according to the
following order of area that is we are
saying counties
Central and then your county so we can
basically choose in which particular way
we would want to do it so it is County
Central and then again County so if I
look into my G3 so here I basically have
my data which is having some South
County then you have your Central and
then you have your North County so we
would want to sort the data to solar
problem which is according to the
following order so first we go for area
then we go for South County Central and
North County so what we can do is we can
basically have area field selected and I
would want to sort this particular data
so I have South County Central and North
County so I can basically go for custom
sort
and then I can choose which is the value
or column which I'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like
cell values well you can also try to
explore conditional formatting icon if
this is what you would want to use or we
can basically go for just cell values
and here we can say if I would be
interested in first getting my values
for South County so for example I can
say custom list and then I can basically
given the new list here so I can say s
Dot County
and then I would want Central and then I
would want North County
so let's select this
as it exists we can basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with Kelly you have in the 12th
row something like Lang and that's what
we are doing so we can basically arrange
the data in a particular order by
choosing a custom list and then sorting
your data so that's one more simpler
task what we have done where we have
sorted the data in the order where
under our area column we first wanted
South County then we wanted Central data
and then we wanted North County so this
is how you can do it now let's look into
one more problem so it says find all the
houses in the central area and we would
want to basically apply a regular filter
let's let's see how do we do that so we
can click on this and here we have the
data so the problem statement is we
would want to find all the houses in
Central Area now how do we do that we
can do a sorting but we would want to
use the filter which you see here is
implemented so how do you do it so you
can select this area and say for example
I would want to apply filter I can just
go in here and I can say let's get a
filter on my first row and now I have
filters applied so we are interested in
looking into the Central Area houses
let's go in here it says all these
fields are selected that means it shows
everything wherein your area has all
these values let's unselect this and
then I will only be interested in the
central so let's say okay and then say
okay so now you see that the area filter
has been applied and we are looking at
the central column so what we have done
is we have applied a simple filter and
we are looking at our data at any point
of time if you do not want the filter
then what I can do is I can select this
and I can say well I'm interested in all
the data so I could do this or you can
clear the filters from area and you get
your data back so that's in one way you
can filter out your data so let's look
at an example of sort and filter where
we might have to filter the data based
on two columns or multiple columns with
different kind of values where it could
be and and or condition now say for
example this is the data I have and this
is the question which we need to answer
such as find the list of all houses in
the central region with pool and South
County without pool now if it was a
simple filter based on one cell I could
have just selected my header row I could
have then applied the filter
and once I have the filter I can look in
area where I have three regions so I'm
only interested in Central and South
County so I can get rid of North County
and that's fine but then we have two
different conditions here so we need the
data in central region to have the value
for pool being true
and for South County the value has to be
without pool now how do we do that so
what we can do is we can first create a
copy of these headers here so let me do
that now the area has to be South County
so basically I can either just select
this and I can choose this value
and then I can select this and then I
can choose Central so that's the
criteria which I have and the pool value
has to be so central region should be
with pool so then this one
basically has to be true
and this one has to be basically false
so south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now to get my result we
can always place your cursor here and
you can check this is M column and
eighth row okay so we would want the
result here so let's go ahead and now
click on data and then in filter you
have an option called Advanced and here
what I can do is I can say I would want
to filter the list in the place but
that's not what I would want to do so
I'll say copy to another location and
here if you see the list range will tell
me that this is the data so A1 to J 126
so a to J column selected and all the
rows
criteria range is basically based on
what I have given here so that is m
from 1
to V which is 3
so I'm selecting these columns and then
I am saying all the way whatever
criteria I have given and copy 2 I am
saying M8
to V8 so that basically will give me my
filtered result so you could basically
just say okay and now I have my data
which has been filtered and I have my
area which is South County that is
without Pool Central with pool again
South County without pool and then if
you look at your central value that's
pool so this is an advanced filter which
we have applied where simply we have
filtered the data based on two columns
and then we have our result so in this
way you can have your customized filter
applied on two different columns and get
your data which can be either replacing
the existing content or in the same
sheet in different set of columns and
rows you can have your result let's look
at one more example of filtering where
you are trying to filter the data data
based on a and condition condition being
met in two different columns and then
you would want to filter out the data
for only specific columns so the
situation is the agents with a house in
North County that should be County area
having two and a single type family so
we are talking about two bedrooms and we
would basically have a single type
family and here the criteria is that if
we would want to only populate these
columns which is Agent area bedroom and
type now what you can do is as I
explained earlier that you can get your
result in the same sheet in a different
location so here I have created these
headers which says agent area bedrooms
and type now this is basically a copy of
all the columns what we have here agent
data listed area list Place bedrooms
bath square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here and this is where we will give our
Advanced criteria to filter the data so
the conditions which need to be met is
we need to look at North County so for
example here in area I can basically go
ahead and select one of the values North
County now the criteria is having two
bedrooms only so let's say bedrooms and
let's say the value should be 2
and then basically I am saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type I
can give the criteria single type so
this is my and condition so we are
saying North County area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if I select this this one tells me
that this is m one row onwards till V
2 so this is what we have and we would
want to filter based on this so let's go
ahead and then go for data filter
Advanced and here in advanced it says
filter the list in place now that's not
what we would want to do so I'll say
copy to another location this basically
selects the list range so which is
telling me A1
2 J 126 so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on M1 V2 which we have given
here and copy to I would say for example
from M7
P 7 now this is the area where I would
this is the place where I want the
result let's say okay and now I get my
data which is based on the question
which has been asked that you would want
the agents with a house in North County
area having two bedrooms and single type
family so in this way you can basically
do Advanced filtering get your data and
get it stored in the sheet anywhere at a
different location well I could have
also done filtering in place and that
would have replaced the data
which we have but that's not what we
want we would want the filtered result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some Advanced filtering we can
also use Excel to filter out the data in
one particular column which might be
conditional or say using some numerical
filters now here say for example the
problem statement is that you would want
to display all the houses whose list
price is between
000 to 600 000 or say for example we
would want to filter out the data to
something else say for example let's say
I have I would want to filter out the
data between 300
000 and 400 000 so we can basically
update this say for example I am saying
I'm interested in 300
to
400. 1000 and that's the criteria to
filter out the data now there are two
different ways or there are two easier
ways to do it one is I would want to
look at the list price so I can select
this I can go ahead and do a filter here
and in the list price now this is where
we would want to do the filtering so
it's pretty easy you can click on this
one and then you can go into number
filters and you can choose between now
that's one easier way of doing it so I
could basically select this I could say
I am looking for Value which is greater
than or equal to three hundred thousand
and then is less than or equal to 400
000 so if I just do this I have applied
my filter and I have my data which is
filtered based on my criteria right so
that's one easier way of doing it or let
me do a control Z
now let the filter be there which you
can anyways use but what we can also do
is as we have seen earlier methods so
get a
set or get your column headers here
and then you are giving two columns here
now the only difference between
my
this set of columns which I have one two
three four and then you have 7 and 10
columns and if you see here we have 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 right so whenever you want
a and condition you will basically
add the columns where I can give add
condition if it is the same column if it
was a different column then it would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie in the same line and
or condition would lie in a different
line now here I can give this value so I
am looking for listed price being
between 300 000 so I am saying it should
be greater than or equal to 300
000 and then I can say less than or
equal to 400
000 now that's my criteria and then I
need my result here which is in M 7 so
what I can do is once I have given my
criteria which I will be using to filter
I can get into Data I can get into
advanced and then I can say copy to
another location so it is selecting my
A1 to J 126 criteria range is based on
M1 to W 2 and then I would want my
result from this particular column so
let's say okay and now you have your
data filtered out in a different
location in the sheet which has been
filtered based on your and condition so
you can filter out the data in this way
or you could just apply a filter on a
column and give the conditions
now let's solve one more interesting
problem and here we would want to use
Excel where we would have an and and an
or condition so say for example this is
the data given to you and the question
is that you would want to find all the
houses in North County again that's a
spelling mistake but then they are North
County area with a list price greater
than 300 000 and having three or four
bedrooms so the bedroom has conditional
so it has R 3 and 4 and then basically
you have list price which is greater
than 300 000 now I could have obviously
selected The Columns and then basically
gone for a filter so I can just do a
filtering here and then I'm looking for
list price being greater than 300 000 so
which we can always given number filter
and I can say great then and then I can
say greater than or equal so I can say
greater than and then I can give 3030
300 000 and that's basically the filter
which we would want and here I would
want to select the bedrooms which should
be just either three or four so if for
example here I go in here and I unselect
this and then I say 3 and 4 right so I
am getting my data which is greater than
300 000 and it should have the bettering
values which will be either 3 or 4
selected now that's one way of doing it
let's do a control Z and get it back
to as we were or you can even just say
clear filter so you get your data back
as it was so what we can do is we can
hear
give the criteria
so for example I have my list price now
this is what I would want as a condition
so let's say greater than three hundred
thousand
300 000 and bedrooms should be three
and then I can say greater than 300 000
and then I can say 4 so this one
basically gives me a situation where
your list price has to be greater than
300 000 and bedroom should be either
three or four so we have given our
filtering criteria now to get the result
what we can do is we can go into Data we
can go into advanced and we can say copy
to another location so our list range is
selected which is columns a to J row
number 1 to 126 your criteria range is
given in M1 to V3 where we have
specified and we are saying the result
would be in M 7 to V7 so if I do this
now I have got the same data which we
were seeing earlier and here the bedroom
values are three or four and basically
the list price is greater than 300 000.
so this is a simpler way in which you
can create your filters and all this
Advanced filtering what we are seeing it
will be saved with your sheet you can
always go back and change this value or
you could do filtering where one person
has to look into the filter to see what
values have been selected
now that we have looked into some
operations which we can perform in Excel
using filter or sorting the data
creating your tables let's also quickly
look at functions and formulas which can
be used for doing some easy calculations
or computations now Excel can be used in
different kind of data analysis so for
example you have different inbuilt
functions which can be used and we can
always check for a particular function
so for example if I had if I wanted to
look at a particular function I could
just type in here something for example
is and then it shows me all the possible
functions and you can always have a look
at the detail of the function for
example you have is even which will
return true if the number is even if we
would say is logical so I could search
for is logical and that tells me whether
a value is logical value true or false
and returns your value true and false
now we can obviously
say subtotal so you can search for any
of these useful functions and that tells
me what this function can be used for so
returns a subtotal list or a database
you have many other such functions such
as integer sum average you may be
interested in working on truncating
some data getting the absolute value
getting the square root basically
getting a count or getting a max value
you can look for any particular
functions within your Excel sheet now
you also have other functions such as
now or time for example let's look at
Now function so I can search for
now
and here it is so this is Returns the
current date and time formatted as it
date and time so this is the function
which we would want to use and if I just
give the function it tells me what is
the current time let's first look at the
description of time here so say for
example I would want time it says
converts hours minutes and seconds given
as numbers to an Excel serial number
formatted with a time format so for
example if I would say two hours and
then 30 minutes and 30 seconds and if I
do this it has basically converted this
into your time format so you can always
use different inbuilt functions for your
work now we will also look at some
Advanced functions like sumf or some ifs
you have countif and countifs and you
can be working on various
functionalities of excel to easily help
you in doing some calculations
computations working with your data
working with your different cell values
so let's look at some example of using
functions like sum or sum if so for that
let's go to this sheet and here we have
some data now I have already applied a
filter which can allow me to filter out
the data so it says find the total units
that were sold in the east region now we
know that in region we have east
and
I have multiple regions I could
basically be saying unselect all and
select only East
and say okay and that basically gives me
the units which were sold and if I place
my cursor here and then if I did a auto
sum so it would basically give me
the function which is being used so
something like subtotal and it is
basically working on your rows which is
E2 to e44
and here we can just do this so that
gives me the total but this is this is
fine you could do that but
it would be good if we know how do we
use a function like sumif to do that so
here I am seeing this is the subtotal
where I am looking at the values and
basically what I have done is I have
filtered out the region and then
basically I am getting a count but this
does not give me clearly how a sum was
calculated from all the values which
were listed what we can also do is let's
do a control Z and let's get it back so
now we have our data and we would want
to get the total units that were sold in
the east region so what I can do is I
can start typing in my formula and for
that I'll use an inbuilt function so for
example I would be interested in going
for sumif now it says sum if adds the
cells specified by a given condition or
criteria when you talk about some ifs
this is when you could give set of
conditions or multiple criteria so let's
look at some if let's do this now
obviously this gives me an error because
the formula
is not right so we have to basically
come in here and let's start with sum if
now when I say sum if it shows me there
is a function with sum if which we would
want to use and here once I open up the
bracket it tells me okay what is the
range of data which you are interested
in so I am interested in all the units
that were sold in the east region so we
are interested in the region
which is here so I can basically be
selecting this and this tells me
you are interested in the data here so
let's not take the header value so let's
say B2 and then we can go all the way to
the end so we can basically select this
way
that's the data we have select this and
hit enter so now here it has selected B2
to B4 but we need to basically now give
the criteria so the criteria is either a
value or you can point it to a cell
which has that particular value so as
per our problem statement we are looking
for the units which are sold in east
region so I can select the value East
here and then my sumif needs the range
on which you want to
calculate a sum so
let's select this and now we are
interested in finding out the sum of
units so that's basically this column e
column so I can basically type in
instead of selecting so I can say e and
I'm interested in e 2 2 e 44 so that
basically selects the area or all the
values and now let's do this so that
basically gives me the sum is 691 right
now this is the criteria where I have
pointed it to a cell and whatever value
that cell has well I could have done
something like this so I could have
selected East giving the value and then
doing it it still does the same thing
and in this way you have more clarity
that you are using sumif you are
filtering the data so you have given the
rows you are given the criteria and then
you have given the range on which you
would want to sum up the values now
similarly if the question was what was
the total revenue generated from binder
now we would want to find out what is
the total revenue generated from binders
that means my filtering criteria will be
binder
and then I want to find out the total
revenue generated so we have the revenue
generated field also here and we have we
don't have any region to be filtered we
are just looking for binder so let's
again start doing the same thing so we
can go for some if we can open the
bracket now it needs the range so we are
interested in revenue generated now
that's the summation we want and we
would want to
get the range of data so here we can
basically select
uh d
D 44
so that's the data selected now I would
want to give the filtering criteria so
let's say binder and then we need to
give the range on which the sum needs to
be calculated so that's my Revenue
column so that's G so I can say G to to
G 44 and that basically selects the
column and then you get your sum so it
tells me what is the total revenue
generated from binder now I could be
doing this for other things also so say
for example if you would want to filter
out something else you could basically
just drag and drop here and then I could
come here and change this to say instead
of binder I would be interested in say
pencil
if that's the criteria in you are
interested in remember to change this so
that you take all the values
and here we will change
it to select the relevant rows and then
this is the date I am getting so I know
that this is the revenue generated
from pencil this is the revenue
generated from binder now this is a
simple use case where we are using some
if what if we would want to use some IFS
so sum ifs let's have a look at how we
get to some ifs so sumif says where you
would want to work on
doing some calculation but then you
would want
multiple criterias to be met so let's
see how we get this so here what I can
do is let's work on this problem
statement which says what is the total
revenue generated from central region
where the item is a pencil so that's
something which I would want to check
now when we are answering this question
we can also look at the order in which
things have been asked in the question
so it says what is the total revenue
generated from central region so we need
the total revenue generated we know
there is a revenue column we are
interested in getting the total revenue
generated
we are saying the filtering criteria is
central region and we say in that we
would be interested only in the item if
it is pencil how do I do it so I can use
sumifs where you can pass in multiple
criteria so let's start with some IFS
and when I start with some ifs let's
open up the bracket so it says sum range
it says criteria range then it gives one
criteria and you can give in any number
of criterias so for example we are
interested in total revenue generated
now that's my G column so let's follow
in the same order so let's say G 2
so that's my first value and then I know
there are 44 rows here so I can say G 44
and you can obviously check if that has
selected all the rows now that's my
total revenue generated so I would want
the total revenue generated so I'm
saying setting this some range
then I need to give the criteria range
so it says from central region so
central region comes into column two
that's B so let's say b 2 to B 44 so
that's my criteria range then you have
to give your criteria but we need to
filter out the region being Central so
let's select this now either I could
point to a value in the cell or I can
just give the exact value here
we can also give a
wild card or matching pattern so that
also works now this one is fine we are
now also interested in finding the total
revenue generated when the region is
Central and the item is pencil how do we
do that so for
item we know the columns the column is
D2 so let's select d 2 2 D 44 so that
basically selects all the rows in the D
column and we need to give the
filtering criteria so let's do a comma
and then just given our value so let's
say pencil and then let's close your
bracket and that basically gives you the
result
so we need to just follow the order of
our question which says
what is the total revenue generated so
we are looking at the revenue column we
are selecting all the rows
then it says from the central region so
we need to select the region column and
give the filtering criteria Central or
point to a cell which contains that
value and then it says we would be
interested only in item being pencil so
then you select the column which has all
the items and provide you a filtering
criteria that is pencil so that's your
easy calculation of using some if which
we compare with sum if here so sum if
here was just having
your criteria
so basically you are selecting your rows
giving your filtering criteria and then
your sum range in some ifs we are giving
multiple condition now same thing can be
done here it says how many units were
sold by sales representative Johns or
Jones where the cost of each item was
greater than 4. so how many units were
sold by sales representative
so when we talk about how many units
that's your e column
so let's start with that so let's say
sumifs I would be interested in E column
and let's give the range so it says sum
range so those are the number of units
on which we would want to find the sum
then it says you need to give the
criteria range so we say sales
representative where the name is
Jones so sales representative is in
sales rep column C so let's say C2 to
c44
now
then we need to give our filtering
criteria so let's say Jones
is the sales representative where we are
interested about whom we are interested
in and then we the question says where
the cost of each item
so cost of each item is what we are
interested in you have unit cost
so that's what we are interested in so
that would be f
and then say F2 to f44
and then you need to give your cost so
it says where each item is greater than
so let's select this
and let's
do this so this tells me 3 0 1. now
similarly let's answer our third
question which is how many units did
Jones sell excluding
pencil item so we would want to find out
what was the total number of units units
that were sold
and that units or that should not
include the pencil item how do we start
doing this so let's start with some IFS
now we know that you start with some ifs
you need to give the sum range so we are
interested in the number of units so
let's basically go in and select our
number of units which were sold so
that's your column e so I can say E2 to
e44 that's where I would want to perform
the sum now I am saying
how many units that were sold where
we are talking about sales rep being
zones so let's see let's select the
columns
C and then give
the range
after that we need to give our giving
filtering criteria which is Jones and
then we are interested in the items but
excluding pencil so items is in column D
so let's say d to d44 and then we have
to give
are criteria so we can say well that
should exclude pencil
so I can basically say
pencil
and let's close this
and let's check so that's my formula
which says that these are the number of
units which the sales representative
whose name is Jones had sold and that
does not include pencil as an item let's
also look at an example of using countif
or countifs now both of these can be
very useful when you would want to
calculate certain values so for example
if I would want to work on count if
let's try solving this problem now
remember you can answer these questions
using filters and that can be an easier
way but then sometimes you may want to
get the formulas so that you can make
your spreadsheet and your calculation
more
dynamic in nature and that will
basically depend on the values in the
columns or rows so for example if I have
find the total number of times Gill has
made a sale now if I look at my data
here it tells me that for every sales
representative there is some value in
the sale and it says sales has greater
than 3 so for example Jones you have
sales greater than three or you have
Jardine which is sales greater than 3
and so on so what we are interested in
is doing a quick count and finding out
the total number of times Gill has made
a sale how do we do that so we can use
this count if function and if I go into
countif it says counts the number of
cells within a range that meet the given
condition now what's our condition our
condition is Gill and we would want to
find out how many times the name say
Gill appears or kill has made a sale now
I could just say count if and then open
up a bracket I need to give a range so
let's say we are interested in looking
at the range so let's say we will choose
sales rep so I can say C and then I can
say c 2 2 C 44 now that's my range
let's not give that in quotes
so you have to give a range so let's do
a count if that selects the data and
then we need to give the condition so
for example let's here give the name
which is Gill and then close this so
that basically tells me it is five times
kill appears here we can check this so I
can go in here I can add a filter and
then might be I would be interested in
looking at only Gill
and that basically gives me five right
so we can always do that and we can be
using formulas like this now what about
this question so which basically says
which sales representative made a sale
more than three times now we it might be
looking a little confusing when I say
for example let me clear out this filter
now we have sales greater than three and
we would want to find out which sales
representative made a sale more than
three times now I could basically check
for every sales representative here if
they have made a sale more than three
times and what I can do is I can just
say equals I can start with count if
then I need my filtering criteria so
that's your range so first thing is we
will choose for example is choose C2 to
C 44 and then we need to
give and criteria what is the criteria
we need basically a sales representative
so I can choose the value here in C2
and then I can close this and then I can
say the sale has to be greater than 3
and let's check so it tells me the
Boolean value that yes this guy has made
sales more than three times and what we
can do is we can just drag and drop
which basically gives me the value for
other sales rep you can always check the
value is automatically changing to this
value in cell and for example let's go
in here so this is obviously 2 so it
says me false right and you can
basically get the values for all your
values so that basically tells me which
sales representative has made a sale
more than three times
now like sumifs we also have countifs
where you can give multiple criterias so
for example the question is how many
orders were placed from the east region
after this particular date so we have
a date criteria we also have the region
criteria and we need to basically get
the count of number of orders which were
placed now I can in this case use count
ifs
and this basically says that you can
start with an criteria so it says how
many orders were placed from east region
after particular date so date is in my
First Column so for example I could say
a
start with 2 and say for example let's
go a 44 that should have selected all
the rows
and then I need to
once I have given the criteria range I
need to give the criteria so we are
saying the date has to be greater than
10th Feb so let's give it
to
and then you need to say
how many orders were placed so you need
to give the criteria second criteria
range so we are looking at the number of
orders which were placed
from the east region so when I would
want to look at the region that's your
column B so I can basically say B2 to P
and here
I would basically
give my criteria so the criteria is East
let's give that
and once you have done this you would
want to find out the total number of
orders so let's select this and if I do
this it tells me 13 now is that right so
we are looking for your date
your region being East and then getting
the total number of orders so here I can
just do a count if I'm saying A2
to a44
wherein I have given the date criteria
that it should be greater than
10th Feb because I do not want to count
10 Feb it says after 10 February and
then you are saying the region has to be
East so we would want to find out the
total number of orders so my region is
east and that gives me the result
now similarly you can also find out how
many times Gill
sold pencils so here we will have to
give the range so
let's start with count
ifs
now here I would want that item is
pencils so we can as well select column
D two
T 44
then you have to give your criteria so
that's your
pencil
and then we are looking for sales rep
which is Gill so
that is my column C so let's say c 2 2 C
and the value should be
just kill
so it tells me
it's twice where Gill has sold pencils
so we can obviously check this by going
in here
choosing my filter and then let's search
for rep being just Gill
okay and now we are interested only in
the item being pencil so I can say well
let's get to pencil only and that tells
me twice so you can obviously re-verify
using filters but using functions or
using formulas it is always good to
calculate and that can be making your
computation and calculation more dynamic
let's look at one more interesting
feature of Excel and that's your
conditional formatting now as you see on
the screen conditional formatting has
different rules which can be applied on
your data and that allows you to
basically differentiate or easily
identify data values which are
based on certain criterias or rules so
when you talk about conditional
formatting you have different options
such as you can highlight cell rules you
can get top and bottom values you can
apply different rules apply different
color scales and you you can easily
manage these rules
so conditional formatting is very useful
for people who would want to work on
huge amount of data and easily perform
some data analysis
it's easy to use as it is shown here and
with your conditional formatting
you can format cells based on a preset
condition you can perform conditional
formatting to identify cells you can
highlight a few significant cells and
you can easily perform conditional
formatting
as shown on the left side
now how do we work with conditional
formatting let's have a quick look so
say for example we have our Excel sheet
and if you see here I am highlighting
the sales person who have generated
Revenue greater than 10 000.
so we can be looking at the values where
the revenue generated by a particular
sales person is greater than 10 000 it
has a particular
color and how do we get here so for
example let's select this data
and what I could do is
I could go into conditional formatting
now I could basically highlight cell
rules and
just say greater than that's an easier
way I could also go ahead and create a
new rule but then I can use one of this
option I can say greater than and let's
give some value might be we would be
interested in looking at any value
greater than 12 000 so let's choose 12.
thousand
and here it says what color would you
want to select so for example I would
say something like
yellow fill with dark yellow text
and let's say okay so right now what I'm
doing is I have all the values where the
revenue generated was greater than 10
000 but then I have also selected all
the sales people who have made or who
have generated Revenue greater than 12
000. so I can just do a Ctrl Z to see
the previous result now here I had the
values which were greater than 10 000
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than 12 000. so this is one simple
example now we can look at some other
examples say for example you want to
format cells using three color scale so
if you look at the values here I have a
three color scale mainly in green yellow
and red and how do you do this so for
example I can go in here and I can go to
conditional formatting so I would want
to go for color scales and here you can
create different rules so we can set up
a two color scale so we can say format
only values that are above and below
average I can format only cells that
contain something I can get the top and
bottom value so these are different ways
in which I can have a three color based
scale now what I will do is I will
select this and let me show you the rule
which I have so for example I can go
into manage rules and if you see here
there are certain rules which have been
specified now what does that mean so you
would want to specify a three grade
scale so for example if I would want to
look at my first rule it tells me that I
am choosing three color scale I can
choose lowest value percentile and
highest value and that basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is I can
basically
use one of these values I can delete
these rules which I have created so for
example I have all these rules but you
should always carefully remember that
the rules will be applied in the order
shown so for example if I just delete
these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now it does not have any
highlighting now I can go in here I can
say conditional sorry conditional
formatting I could go for color scale so
I could basically go into
new rule so I would want
the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale it says what will
be the color of lowest value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red I can say midpoint
is percentile 50 and then the highest
value is green and if that looks good
let's say okay and now if you see the
lowest values have been highlighted as
red you have mid values and then you
have the positive value so this is a
three color scale and that easily helps
me in identifying the data based on the
cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do is you can basically color
the cells based on their value so what
we are seeing here is if the revenue
generated is greater than average then
that shows in green and if the revenue
generated is lesser than average that's
shows in Orange now how do we do that so
we can basically again manage some rules
so I can basically create a new rule now
here I can select one of the options
which says format only values that are
above or below average and that's the
option I would want to select now I can
select this and it says format values
that are above average so in our case we
had it in green so for example I'll say
above average and then here I can go for
a particular color
so you can go for a particular size so
let's go and look into
the formatting so for example let's
choose yellow
say okay now I'm saying wherever the
cell values are above average it would
be yellow instead of green
and let's go in here let's go and look
into manage rules so this is basically
the rule which we are applying now we
can also add a new rule
and I need to select the values so for
example I will say
here so we had gone for above now we'll
go for below we'll go for format we will
choose red we'll say okay we'll say
now these are basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to your data so right
now it has not been applied so for
example if I select this and then I
could basically choose my area just hit
on enter and similarly you can go in
here and then select your area hit on
enter and say apply say okay and now if
you see I have really chosen bright
colors but then I have said wherever my
revenue generated is above average it
should be in yellow and
below average should be in Red so we
wanted above
average to be in green and below average
to be in Orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always
color code your cell values based on
some rules which you are setting up now
similarly you can also find the top 10
and bottom 10 values and that's pretty
easy so you can just select this and
then you can go into conditional
formatting you can go for top and bottom
values top 10 items bottom 10 items or
you can go in for more rules so you can
say format only top or bottom ranked
values so you have top 10 now you can
choose the color and for example I'll go
for blue
and
I'll say okay so now if you see my top
10 values are blue now similarly I can
add one more rule so I can say new rule
and I can say let's go for top or bottom
let's go for bottom let's go for format
let's say orange
say okay say okay and that's it so now
you have your values which are top or
bottom 10 values so you are using
conditional formatting where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors and here easy
conditional formatting based on
different rules helps us to do that now
similarly you can also have the values
which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing so what we can do is we can
select our columns either you could
apply this to all the columns now here I
have applied this only to Jan and April
now I could apply this for June so let's
say June so you can go for gradient fill
you can go for solid fill you can
obviously just select the color and that
takes care of the things you can say for
example select this and now this is
selected what I would want to might be
format this so I can go in here I can go
into manage rules now that will tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so I can just do a edit
Rule and that basically says this is a
solid fill which is color you have no
border this is basically color as black
now I can go for something like gradient
fill
and I can say okay and now if I say
apply and okay so this basically is Like
Your First Column so you can use
conditional formatting for various use
cases and you can highlight the values
so anyone who would look at the value
would automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be here the revenue is getting
generated or was getting generated but
did not grow Beyond a particular value
and so on now similarly you can also go
in for different options say for example
here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased or say for
example if the revenue was going up for
this particular sales person so here we
are looking at Carol so in Jan the
revenue Generation by sales was very
high then in Feb it was falling down
in March it was kind of stable then in
April it went way below so we can
obviously work on this wherein we can
grade our cell values so what we can do
is we can go in for
highlighting the cell values now you can
go for color scales you can go for Icon
sets and this is where you can choose
your different shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example I would be interested in
looking at the indicators like
directional I could go
using this three arrows I can go in for
this color I can choose directional and
then my values are
automatically using directional now what
we can also do is we can then go into
manage rules and that basically tells me
what rules have been applied so for
example the latest one is the icon set
which I have chosen it shows the
selected columns I can obviously do a
edit Rule and then I can choose so I am
saying the format style is icon sets I'm
not using a data bar I'm not using color
scale now here
I have chosen the style of icons
and then here you can basically give
some values so you have icon which is
green when the value is greater than or
equal to 67 percentage
when I say hyphen or minus it is less
than 67. it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit and easily highlight your
cell values based on this icon set so I
can apply this and that's how I use
conditional formatting so conditional
formatting can be very useful if you
would want to use icon set if you want
to use your data bars if you would want
to highlight particular values if you
would want to color code based on some
calculation if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to just find out
values based on some simple calculation
so conditional formatting is used
extensively by data analysts or people
who are working in business intelligence
teams or people who would want to use
Excel to easily identify the data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value or finding out less
significant or more significant cells to
then pull out values and carry out your
computations calculations or analysis
let's continue learning on using Excel
for various things now we have learned
on conditional formatting and seen how
that can be very helpful let's learn one
more feature of Excel and that's
basically your data validation now this
can be very useful when you would want
to work on validating the data which is
being fed in the cells so you could
limit it to basically a number between a
particular value you could also add some
messages to it if you would want or you
could even
Circle invalid data or clear validation
circles so data validation really helps
us in validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in Excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a Cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered you can also
restrict user to enter only valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be displayed now
that's where you can use your data
validations so let's see how that can be
done so for data validation let's see
some exercises here so for example you
have a name column and you would want to
restrict that the name should accept
only 15 characters now how do you do
that so you can basically select the
cells or you can just select a
particular cell and then we can later
drag the property to other fields now
here once the cell is selected so for
example let's try this out and let's see
if that works so for example example I
will say Peter Johnson
okay and that is basically five and nine
and 12 characters so let's say
Junior
and if I do this it says input length is
greater than 15 do you want to continue
if I say yes right so basically it is
allowing me to add the value here but
then it has basically violated the rule
now this is giving a message to the user
that the username should be entered less
than 15 characters now how do we do that
so for this we can basically select the
column and then we can search for data
Tab and get into Data validation so this
is where you can create or select
different kind of rules so for example I
can go into Data validation I can go
into settings and I can say the text
length and that should be less than 15
now this is the maximum I'm giving and
it says apply these changes to all other
cells within the same settings so I can
do this or I can just drag and drop so I
can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact randomly check in any particular
cell is the rule applied so it says text
length less than 15. so we can basically
Control Data validation in this
particular column and that will allow
only 15 characters it will pop up a
message if the user really wants to go
beyond the particular limit now you also
have similarly date of birth so the
Restriction is date of birth should be
between 10 Jan 1990 to 30 December 1998
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that so we can select the field
we can click on data validation and if
you see here I have selected date and
then date is between and then obviously
you can give a range that is 10 Jan date
1990 12 30 1998 so that's the start and
the end filter which has been applied
and once this is done you can also check
your input messages which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid date
so if you see here on the left there is
a pop-up which is coming up which says
enter a valid date now I can also say
when user enters invalid data show this
error alert so I can say stop I can say
invalid entered
and this is how I have set a rule so for
example if I just do something like this
and that says invalidate entered I can
do a retry it will take me back here but
unless and until I did not give the
right format the date will not be
accepted and again the same thing
applies to all the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have at the rate present in
the value provided now for this we can
use a formula and we can select well I
would want to apply this rule to all
these rows starting from C2 to c14 so
let's get into Data validation let's
look in settings and here we are
choosing custom now within custom I am
choosing what is the formula so I'm
saying is number
and then I'm saying find
at the rate for
the rows C2 to c14 so the only thing we
are concerned about here is the value
should have an email
icon
you can input a particular message you
can say what has to be done for error
alert so for example we can basically go
in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title I'm giving and we can
say email should contain
at the rate so if I do this and if I say
ok now you can test it so you can say A
B C D and that says email should contain
at the rate and basically that will not
allow me to add the values so now you
have the field called salary it says
salary should be greater than 50 000 now
we can limit the values by choosing a
whole number so for example for salary I
can go into Data validation I can go
into settings so here I can say
something like decimal or I can go for
whole number so both of the things are
fine it depends on what kind of values
get into this particular field so if I
say whole number and if I say it has to
be greater than 50 000 so I'm saying the
minimum is 50 000 or I could have given
a decimal and then I can say greater
than less than equal or anything or even
between so I cancel it greater than and
then I can just say okay
now for rank the rule is rank should be
between 100 and 200 so again we can use
a whole number so ranks will generally
not be decimal so this would be whole
number salary is can be a whole number
or it could be decimals so we have
chosen decimal here and in rank if you
click on data validation I have chosen
whole number
I have set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends I can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell okay so now let's
also understand how we can
restrict the values in a particular cell
which might be based on a list of items
now for example here if you see I have
two columns so one column basically has
the values of city names and then you
have places within that particular City
so if I would want to implement a data
validation based on this so for example
if you see here City and that basically
shows me only the four values which can
be entered and if I go to place then it
tells me for Maharashtra I can only
enter Pune Mumbai nashik now how do I do
this so say for example you take an
empty field and you want to restrict the
values of city names so I could select
data validation I could basically select
list and then it tells me you need to
enter the list values that is the source
so you click here and then I can just
select these fields now if I do this and
if I say OK it has implemented a data
validation but if you look into this it
will show me the same thing but then it
shows me some empty cells which did not
have any value so this is fine but it
would be better if we do it in a
different way so I can select this and I
have already given my city names here so
I can just do a data validation and here
in the source let me get rid of this now
I can just have my cursor here I can
select these values and then if I say ok
so now if you see my city names have
been restricted to these values and
that's how you can Implement your data
validation so I have this data
validation here but I will get rid of
this one by just doing a control Z now
I'll come here and say for example I
would want to implement the same data
validation now the easiest way would be
in doing this for all my four cities now
if you see here I have data validation I
could choose Bangalore and if you come
and check here there is no data
validation but we have implemented data
validation here now how is that done so
I could select this or for example I can
go in here I can select data validation
I can select list and then here in the
source I will say for Bangalore the
value value should be these and then if
I basically say okay
now if we see these are the values which
are fed into Bangalore so we could do
this or like what we have done here so
if you can check the data validation
rule I have used list and then I have
said indirect F2 so basically I'm giving
in a formula which relates to the value
which is in for the city Maharashtra so
we could do this or in a simpler way we
could do this and then just drag and
drop here so we could check for
Maharashtra what are the values let's
choose a different city so for example
Kolkata and here I will choose now since
we did a drag and drop it has basically
taken the values of Bangalore so that's
not right so we select this we go into
Data validation and here I can either
feed in the values that is such as
Bangalore I could basically say
something like this Kolkata and I could
say okay so now if you see it shows me
the places in Kolkata now here we have
let's choose a different city so for
example let's go for Delhi and here I
can go to data validation and I can just
say Delhi so this is an easier way of
doing it or if you remember the formula
then what you can do is you can just
give in indirect and then basically
give the value of the cell for which you
would want to
keep in the values so this is how you
can do list validation so you can
provide a list of values and then you
can restrict the values in a Cell which
should be belonging to a particular list
so this is how you do a simple data
validation by restricting the data in
the form of a list
now let's learn about pivot charts and
tables three of your data
it is used in cases where there are
numerous rows and columns in your data
set and it allows you to group your data
in several ways so that you can derive
meaningful information from it now the
visual representation of a pivot table
is termed as a pivot chart now how do we
do that so let's see an example now here
is some data here you see we have some
row labels which basically gives me some
category of items here it also tells me
the sum of sales and basically it gives
me per item what is the total sum of
sales which were made now how do I get
this here so for example if I would want
to delete this and I would be interested
in getting the
total sales under each category of items
now we know that we have
different data here and it's huge for
example on the row end if I just do a
control and right arrow it tells me
what's my right last column and if I
just do a control and down arrow it
tells me there are
9994 rows now I can use this and what I
can do is I can basically work on
insert and go to pivot table now this
basically tells you need to choose the
range now since I have chosen my first
row and First Column it basically has
selected the data and that's fine now do
you want the result in a new worksheet
I'll say existing worksheet and I can
choose a location now that basically
needs me to select a field might be we
can just select this field and that
should be good enough so for example if
I close this or if I say ok so
this is basically an indication that my
pivot table will be created now what are
the fields we are interested in so as
per the problem we need to find out what
the total sales for each category so
let's go in here and let's select the
field category now as soon as you do
that it shows that the rows
which are being selected are for this
column category and now we are
interested in getting the sales so we
would want the sales per category so
let's select this so you see some of
sales is selected now close this and
that's it that's that's your data so it
shows you row labels it tells you what
are the different categories
and it also gives you some of sales
which is per category now this is
one easy example where we have solved
the problem where we have tried to find
what were the total sales under each
category of items so for example let's
have another data set so again you can
just check how many rows we have and it
is basically the same 9994
and if I look in columns it basically
shows me profit is the last column
and here we would want to find out which
category
so for example let me get rid this with
subcategory of items sold the maximum
under each category so we have some
categories here which says furniture and
it shows some sub categories and then it
shows me office supplies and then some
sub categories and same thing with
technology now we know how we got this
data but this is different than what we
were seeing here so here we were just
getting the categories what what we did
not have any breakdown of sub categories
within this particular category and here
you see there is a breakdown and then
basically you can also apply a filter
which basically says what is the data
you want and if you are interested in
finding out a particular value now how
do we do this so for example let me get
rid of this now we know how we can find
out the category of items but we would
want to find out which sub category of
items sold the maximum under each
category so here we are not looking at
sales but we are looking at the quantity
okay so what we can do is we can go to
the first row and First Column click on
insert click on pivot table data is
already selected let's choose existing
worksheet let's choose a location in our
worksheet where we would want to have
this so maybe I can select this
particular field and then just close
this so it says this is the existing
worksheet say okay and now you need to
select your columns so for example
if I would want the data for categories
so I can select this now I know that
within category these are the options
which we have and then there is a
subcategory so let's select that and if
you see here now we have the data which
will be filtered So based on your
category and subcategory and then we
will choose quantity so it automatically
understands that this is something on
which summation can be done so let's
select this and close on this now if you
see here we have got our items where we
can see
the subcategories within a particular
category now I can basically close this
and that just shows me high level
categories here so here I can again
select a particular
row and column I can go for
either a new pivot table so we could
basically select this the row is already
selected existing worksheet is what I
want so now I will select
this particular place
say okay now we do the same thing like
what we did earlier so we will select
category subcategory and quantity so the
data is already coming
just select this and now you already
have all your data but this is not what
we want we want to basically apply a
filter
to this now how do we do that so we can
go for
slicer so I can go for insert slicer and
then it tells what are
the subcategories which you are
interested in so for example if I go for
something like subcategory and say Okay
so this tells me what are the categories
you are interested in so for example we
know that furniture has Furnishings with
the highest value so I can select say
furnishings and then I was interested in
office supplies So within office supply
I can basically
search for
here
binder so I can just do a control and
select binder
and then I can also know for technology
I can select phones so I'll say control
and select phones and now if you see the
filter has been applied and we have
these subcategories which are selected
so we have our data here now we don't
need really this so I can just delete
this and I have my data which shows me
Furniture being the main category and
that has only Furnishings office supply
having binders and Technology having
phones and that basically is a filter
applied on the result of your pivot so
this is how we are seeing with
subcategory of items were sold
maximum for each category
so this is how you can easily use pivot
tables and you can do some analysis
let's look at some more examples
now
let's see if you have to answer this
question which says which were the top
three states for each region that made
the highest average profit now how do we
calculate that so for example this is
the data we have and as I've instructed
earlier you can select the first one
first column you can click on insert go
into pivot table and that basically
selects all your data we will choose the
result should be in this existing
worksheet so select this click here and
then basically let's select
this cell and I will say okay so now my
pivot table will be here so we are
interested in finding out top three
states within each region which have
made the highest
profit or which have made the highest
average profit so for that first we will
select region so when we select region
it shows
here region and within region you will
then select state So within every region
you have multiple States so that's what
we are selecting and then we are
interested in looking at the profit so
let's select profit and that
automatically shows up here so we can
now say close this so basically we have
all the data but we are looking at the
sum of profit but that's not what we
want we are looking for
top three states
from each region that made the highest
average profit now how do we change that
so here we have sum of profits so I can
do a right click and basically I can say
summarize values by average so now I'm
getting the average here and that
basically tells per region I have the
average profit but first is let's sort
this data so let's go into sort more
options and here I have average of
profit or for example as I said you can
select region say okay and now it is
basically having the
regions and then you have your state
value so again we can do a sorting here
and I can say
let's go for more sort options I'll say
descending the state values should be
based on average profit so let's say
okay and now if you see
in particular region we have the data
which has been
sorted wherein you have the highest
average profit on the top now what we
can also do is we can basically
then go for filtering we can say top 10
but I am not interested in top 10 so I
could reduce this to top three
and this is the items average of profit
say okay and now you see per region you
have the data which is
showing me top three states what are the
average and then you are also looking at
the subtotal so which basically says
average profit for your West now if you
would want to arrange this
your west and south and east and Central
in a particular alphabetical order if
you would want to sort it you can always
do a sorting and you can choose sort Z
to A if that's what you would want to do
or you can go for sorting more sort
options and you want to
sort the region which is as of now
based on descending z2a let's make it
ascending say okay and now you see the
data has been filtered so it says per
region now you can always select this
and you can say what is this so this is
basically your average of profit now we
are looking at
each region and the states the top three
states as we wanted within the region
and what is the average now we have one
more question what is the percentage
contribution of each sub-category of
products under each category to the
total sales so we know there are
different products there are different
categories and all the categories
contribute to the total sales so we
would want to find out what is the
percentage contribution of each
subcategory
of products under each category so we
not only want the category percentage
but we would also want what is the
contribution of each subcategory
to
each category to the total sales how do
we do that so for that we need to again
just place
our cursor here or select the first row
and First Column click on your insert
click on your pivot table and now the
data is already selected existing
worksheet place your cursor here and
then let's select this cell say okay
now your pivot table fields are here so
we are interested in category
so let's select category and then within
a category we will have subcategories
and we are interested in the sales data
wherein it is already going to give us
the sum of sales but we would want this
in the form of percentage rather than
just the sump now we can click here
value field settings and it says if you
would want to summarize this it says
show value as and what are the values
you would want so you can straight away
go ahead here and say percentage of
grand total so we could do that because
we know
we will get a sum of sales and grand
total now I could basically say
percentage of grand total say okay and
then just close this
so once you have closed this you see
already the data is in
percentage so now we have our data with
subcategories but we also want the data
to be sorted might be in a descending
order which tells which subcategory is
contributing more than others we can
select how many sub
to a particular category and also to
total sales so technically speaking if
you look at all these values which are
subcategories and if you would total
them that would be your total grand
total so this is how we can solve a
simple problem like this what is the
percentage contribution of each
subcategory of products under each
category to the total sales
the next question is which customer made
the lowest profit in the home office
segment in each state now here we know
that we are looking for home office
segment we are looking for customer
which made the lowest profit we are also
looking for the state as the main
criteria so in each state we would look
for home office segment and within that
we would look for customer which has
made the lowest profit that means
the lowest value
of the profit so how do we do this so
let's say let's get into selecting our
row and column we will go into insert
I'll say pivot table I'll say existing
worksheet and let me get my result here
so let's say okay now that gives me the
PO table so the first thing is we are
looking at per state
and
I would be interested in
home office segment or I could first
start with segment now here we have
segment and in segment I can basically
select home office so I can just do a
uncheck and select home office only
and now I can select
state so that will be my
subcategory within segment and then
within State we would want to find out
the customer so let's get the customer
name
and we are interested in finding out the
lowest profit so let's select profit and
here we have sum of profits so the
fields are selected close this and now
you have your data
which basically shows me the names of
customers which made the profit but it's
it's not sorted so we can sort this and
we have state entries also so that's
fine so what I can do is here I can
basically say sorting go to more sort
options I can say I want to do it
descending or I want to do an ascending
an ascending based on sum of profit so
let's do that now you see the top most
value is the lowest value per state
within home office segment now what we
also want is we just want one value per
state so how do we do that so we can
just go for filtering go for top 10
values I am interested in bottom value
and in that also I am looking for only
the
lowest value so let's select one
say okay and now you see we have data
for home office segment
per state
customer who has made the lowest profit
so we have easily answered this question
using our pivot table
now say for example we have a question
which says find the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions
so the data has to be divided quarterly
and use order here as a slicer we can do
that by selecting what data we would
want to slice and then we would want to
create a pivot chart also so for example
how do we do that so for example I will
get rid of this
I will get rid of
this my Pivot chart which we can
recreate so find the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions so
this is what we want now how do we do
this so for example let's select this we
will do a insert pivot table we will
basically say existing worksheet and
then I can select this particular cell
I'll say okay and now I am interested in
data quarterly so first let's select
our field here so we should basically
have
if all our fields are selected say for
example if I say order date
now
you see we have quarters and years which
are selected now we could be selecting
these fields which says
quarters years and if I would want data
to be filtered based on years I could do
that or I could get rid of here so I
have quarters I have ordered date
so
that's being already selected now what
else we need we need to find out
for every region so let's select the
region and we can also add region as a
column here so that will basically give
me all the regions as different columns
and then finally we want the sales so
let's select this
and now let's look what we have so if
you see here
we have our data which is
for each quarter
it gives me the total data but what we
would be interested in is not looking at
the total data but we are only
interested in quarter of
2016. now how do we do that so what we
do here is we have row labels so let's
click on this so we have date filters
and then in date filters we can go for
between and then we will say
2016 and the value has to be 1 and then
let's select this and let's change this
to 2016.
and this is 12th month
and then we can say 31
so we are saying the date has to be
2016.
and it basically says not a valid date
so let's select
let's select a particular date and see
so the month has to be here
so let's see in this and let's make it
date and say okay and now we have our
data which is
foreign
2016. so for example I could basically
select this and here I could be looking
at
what are the filters we have so it says
clear filter from order data so we have
applied the filter on order date
and
these are your date filters which is
basically
date 16 or this is wrong so this one has
to be changed to 2016. so select this
and now we have our data for 2016.
so we have found the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions the
grand total
for a particular quarter if we are
looking at the value or for individual
months in a particular quarter and we
have sliced the data now we could have
also introduced a slicer by
selecting
which field we would want to implement
so for example if I would select a
particular field and then I could click
on slicer I could choose I would want to
slice the date based on order date and
then could have done it or we have just
given the
date for 2016. now we just need to plot
a graph for this and that's very easy so
you just need to select the complete
pivot data and here you have the chart
options so let's go for line chart and
that basically shows me the line chart
so we can select this we can just drag
and drop it here and then we can
basically check if that is showing us
the data so if you see here this is line
chart where it has divided the regions
in different colors so we have all the
regions we could filter out in pivot
chart a particular region we have the
quarterly
time here in order data the filter is
applied it says it is
2016. in quarters it tells me it is 16.
so we have our data we have created a
pivot chart and basically we have sliced
the data for 2016.
let's answer one more question and
that's finding the profit made in each
year for all the categories of products
in east and west regions only and then
we would want to create a histogram for
the same pivot table so histogram
usually gives us the frequencies so
let's look at how do we calculate the
profit made in each year for all the
categories so what I can do is I can
basically
select my row ID here and now I'll do a
pivot table so the data is already
selected I'll choose existing worksheet
let's select this particular cell say
okay now what are we interested in now
if you look at the fields we don't see
any years or quarters and so on so for
example here I can just choose order
date
and then basically
I can choose say for example years or
quarters the data which is coming out
from my order date so here I will just
select years
now
then I have my order date so
we are interested in the Years orders
and
we are interested in
let's look at our column or the question
what we had here
so we have years
find the profit made in each year so
let's select profit so that basically
says sum of profit but then I'm on also
interested in
for all the categories of products so
what I can do is here I have my field
which is category and that I'll add to
the columns so that shows me what are
the different categories
and this looks fine now I'm also
interested in east and west regions so
that is basically in the region so
either we could add a slicer or we could
do a filtering here by adding the
filters so first is I'll click on region
and here it says select all I'm only
interested in east and west so let's
select this
take this put it here
let's say okay and now we have the data
which has been filtered based on the
region so here we have region so you can
always look at the filter it is east and
west and we have our year data per year
we have different categories you can
always look at what are these column
labels so this is my different
categories and this is the profit per
category
and then you have your grand total so we
have already our data now let's say
close this so we have our data for all
these years different categories the
profits made per year and if I would
want I could go into an year and I could
look into different months so that also
is showing up and now we would want to
basically plot a histogram with this
data so I can just place my cursor here
I can select this and then I can go into
insert and here I have different options
so we can go for bar chart we can go for
insert hierarchy chart
we can go into waterfall funnel stock
surface or radar chart so there are
different options what you have here and
we will go for a simple histogram which
is two dimensional let's select this and
here you see you can obviously select
different regions
you have your ears which shows up you
have your order date
and then you have your categories which
can be chosen for your histogram or for
your bar chart and that basically is how
you use your pivot table you use some
calculations and then you can plot your
needed graph to visualize the data and
understand it in a better way hi
everyone welcome to this tutorial on
Microsoft Excel let's look at an example
of one more useful function in Excel and
that is vlookup now vlookup is used to
see if a value exists in a range of
values and we can create a range of
values which is nothing but a block of
cells which has a name and can be
referenced so mainly to use vlookup we
need to create a named range and that
can be referenced anywhere in the
workbook or the other option is you can
always drag and select uh the range of
data in which you would want to search
something now there is also uh other
functions such as Edge lookup which
pretty much does the same thing however
it does it horizontally that is left to
right instead of vertically there are
other functions like lookup and X lookup
and so on so when we talk about vlookup
let's see how we do that so for example
this is the range of or this is the data
which has been given to you and here is
the question find the employee name with
employee id107 now assume that you might
have huge amount of data and you may
want to search something so how do we do
it now here I have created some column
and then some basic formatting I have
given it as an employee ID I have given
the employee name now what I can do is I
can create a range of data now how do I
do that or a named range so what you can
do is you can select the data and then
you can do a right click now here you
have something like get data from table
range so you can do that you can define
a name so you can click on this
and here you can give a name to the
range what you would want to call it so
for example let's say our search now
that's the named range I'm creating and
just say Okay so the scope is workbook
and I have created a named range which
you can see here so it shows for search
our search so you have created a named
range now how do we do a vlookup here so
for that we can use a formula so for
example I would want to search for
employee name where employee ID is
whatever you would want to search for so
employee ID we can give here one zero
seven now that's what we would want to
search the employee name for an employee
name is what we are interested now what
we can do is we can use the function
option here I can do a insert function
and that shows me different functions
which I have here now vlookup is showing
up because I have recently searched for
it or you can basically just type in
here look and you can do a go so that
shows you all the lookup options what
you have like look up Edge lookup match
vlookup and so on so we would be
interested in vlookup so let's select
that and click on ok now that basically
opens up this function arguments and it
shows what does this function do so it
says looks for a value in the leftmost
column of a table
and then returns a value in the same Row
from a column you specify by default the
table must be sorted in an ascending
order now you can basically say this is
what you would want to search for what
is the lookup value if you place your
cursor here it says what is the table
array that is nothing but the range
which we can use our named range here we
have the column index number which
basically tells me what is the column
number in the range which we want so
what is the value we want from which
column and then basically you have range
lookup which basically is the fourth
option and range lookup is nothing but
it can have two values so true or false
so true basically means closest match
and then false should be an exact match
so let's do that so for lookup value we
would want to give a particular value
which is nothing but
we would be interested in say employee
name so I can basically
search for a value based on the lookup
value now how do we do it so we are
saying we would want to search for
employee ID which is one zero seven so
what I can do is I can select this
cell here which tells that this is the
value
or employee ID for which I would want to
search the employee name I could
actually select the cell here which is H
so that whatever value you feed in here
you can search for that value so maybe
we can select this one which is H6 and
whatever value we key in here we will be
searching for employee name for that
employee ID now table array is we would
want to give a range so what we can do
is we can give our range so for example
we had selected something like our
search
and if you see here that already selects
or shows me employee ID employee name
email address so it gives me the range
now column index number so which
column are we interested in that means
what is the value we are searching for
so we are searching for employee name
which is the second column so I can just
say 2 and that basically is the column
number and then you have to give a range
lookup which is a logical value so
either you give an exact match or you
can basically give a closest match so we
can say for example do a 0 which
basically means false or you can say 1
which is true so let's go for zero now
that's our formula so it says vlookup
you will search for the value as per at
6 in the range and then you are looking
for employee name which is column number
two and then true or false so let's
click on OK and that basically gives me
the value which is parallel
bunch
so here I am searching for employee name
and you can basically drag this for
other columns and you can do that so if
it finds employee
ID here now say for example if we had an
employee ID somebody enters an employee
ID which is not in the range for example
let's try 121 and then you see this is
basically an error right because it does
not have any employee ID with 121 now
how do I take care of this so there is a
Formula which is called if error and
that can be used to take care of this so
if the value is not found then it will
show whatever I would want to
show here so what I can do is I can
still select this and what I can do is I
can search in function
say for example this is the function we
are looking at but what we can do is
we can test it here so for example if I
look in function and if I search for
error and say oh go so there are lots of
functions here and this is the function
we are interested in if error so if I
say okay now this takes the value and
what is the value if error so for Value
what I can do is basically I can select
the value from here which is nothing but
our vlookup formula and value if error
so for example I will basically say for
example not found so we can try this and
we can say okay now here it says not
found so whenever it is n a it is not
found now
if we look at the formula here it says
if error it takes the value of H7 which
is nothing but our vlookup and then it
is
showing us the value which we have
entered so for example if I would say 1
0 7 like earlier and then hit on enter
so it says panel of cruise and it shows
us the value
right and if we enter something else
then basically
here it shows n a and it shows not found
but what we want to do is we want to
merge these two so what I can do is I
can get rid of
or I can basically take this one
now what I would want is I want this
formula to be here so what I can do is I
can say if error and then basically
given your vlookup option or function
here and then say for example not found
here not found now that basically will
take care of any kind of error if the
value is not found so when we say 121 it
basically says not found but if I say
107 which is found then it shows me the
value so we are using vlookup but when
then we are also using IF error which
will take care of our error message or
basically the not applicable pound not
applicable replaced with whatever value
we key in similarly we can do the same
thing here so we have the find the job
title so we are interested in finding
about the job title once the employee
name is given now employee name can
basically have a value from the cell or
whatever value you would want to key in
how do we do it so we basically start
with are we lookup so that's the
function we are interested in
so you can just do a double click now
you are interested in finding out the
value whichever is given here so that's
the lookup value and then you are
interested in finding out the job title
from the range so I will still give our
range which basically
also shows for example let's do a
double click here and that basically
selects the range and now I am
interested in finding out the job title
so that's column number four
and then I can just give 0 which is for
false so now we have given our vlookup
but that shows not applicable because we
have not given any employee name so we
can key in the value here which says
Fred Stone and now if we are basically
giving the value so Fred Stone now we
will have to search if there is any job
title which is Fred Stone so here is the
value so that should be showing up let's
check what has gone wrong so we are
giving our range we are interested in
finding out the value but what the
mistake what we did here was that when
we want to search for a value say for
example let's take this vlookup and
let's replace this value of H to L with
the value here so Fred Stone and then
basically we will give our range we will
save which is the column we are
interested in and then give true or
false so we can also basically take care
of this error message so for example
let's take this complete formula from
here and just
just copy this formula
and now we can put in here the formula
but then this is where we were searching
for H6 which was employee ID now that's
not what we are interested in we are
interested in finding out the value so
let's take this one and replace this
with the value given here
and then I give my range I say which is
the column I'm interested in so I'm
interested in looking for job title and
then let's search so it basically tells
me not found so let's check this
now the error which we were facing was
because when we talk about your vlookup
let's look at the formula again and here
say for example I go for function and
then I select vlookup and say for
example I say okay now just look at the
description here looks for a value in
the left most column of a table now
earlier the range which we had selected
had the leftmost column as employee ID
and that's why it was giving an error so
how do we fix that so for example let's
basically
remove this function from here now what
we want to do is we would want to search
for the stock broker now if you see here
I have given a range which is b 1 to D21
so we would want the value for what we
would want to search say employee name
that should be the leftmost column so
so that's how
we have our function so let's do that so
say for example the name is given here
so we want a range so either we can
create a range like earlier by selecting
say for example this data now am I
interested in salary no I am interested
in job title right so I can basically
just select these three columns and then
I can define a name so I can say our
search to and let's give a named range
and that's only because we would want to
easily reference or use that named
search or name range now here we would
want to use vlookup but we would also do
an if error
now within that we can say we lookup and
then you need to
select what is the value what your
function takes so basically this is my
function we will say if the value is not
found then we will give this so you can
create an external structure and then
within your vlookup we will say the
leftmost column which we are interested
in so that's your employee name
so in employee name we have the value so
either I can directly select the value
here in the column b or I will give the
value whichever is fed in here the
employee name
and then I need to give a range so let's
select our range so that's your our
search too and then you need to select
the column number
so we are interested in finding out the
job title so that's the third column so
let's say three and then just give it 0
and then hit on enter so it says not
found because you have not given any
employee name now let's
try to find the job title of Fred Stone
so I can just select or I can say equal
and then I can just given a value and
that basically shows me the job title so
this is how you use vlookup we have also
used if error which basically takes care
of error message if the value is not
found so for example we can test this
here we have Fred Stone
so for example if I just empty this and
I point it to something which does not
exist so that shows me not found or if
you just select this and then key in a
value it shows you this might be we can
just type in so if I say Fred then
basically it says not found because we
are looking for exact match now if we
had changed this to the closest match
something like this then it would have
tried to find something but then we
don't have anything which is just with
this so there are different ways of
doing it so what we can do is we can
always go for the exact match
and that's basically the value
and here we can basically key in any
value for example I would be interested
in finding out
this one and let's give this so you can
search in this way so you can also have
statements which can be searching one
related to other now here the question
was to find the job title of Fred Stone
so let's type in Fred Stone and that
basically shows me the job title which
we are interested in so let's search for
job title let's go for exact match and
then search so it is stock broker so if
getting your learning started it's half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now that we have looked at vlookup it
would be interest
in the on the same lines but here
instead of vertically searching through
the columns the range is more of
horizontally defined so we search in
rows rather than in columns so for
example this is the data which has been
given to you and you have various
columns so you have employee ID you have
your employee name you have employee
email address
you basically have the job title of
different employees and then basically
you have the salary so this is the data
which has been given to you and you are
asked to search or you are interested in
finding out say the salary based on
employee name or job title based on
employee ID so what we need to do is we
need to define the range here now range
can depend on what you are searching for
so for example when I'm searching
employee name and salary so I am
interested in these four rows when I am
saying employee ID and job title then
might be this is the range and I don't
need salary so I can create a named
range if we are interested in so that we
can easily search for it or we can
straight away give the the first cell
value which is basically A1 here and
then the last value here which is G and
then you can give 5. so you can do that
or you can create a named range
whichever way you would want to do it so
for example we would want to create a
named range for our first question which
is find the salary of Eden Cornell using
H lookup so we are interested in this so
let's select
these four rows all the way for your
columns now like we did earlier we can
just Define a name might be we can call
it our search 3 and we can just give
okay so that's the named range which we
have created
now what we would want is we want to
search for the salary based on employee
name so here we can insert our function
so let's look up and let's search for
look and just click on go so here you
have hlookup and basically that's the
function I'm interested in say Okay so
this says what is the lookup value which
you are interested in so we are
interested in finding out the value
based on the employee name so for
example let's select this cell that
gives us more dynamism and you can add
in any name and you can search for the
salary
or you can basically give the employee
name exactly from the employee name
value here which is D 2. so we can give
Aden kernel from here so let's select
this now table array so we need to give
our range so let's say our search three
then you need to give the row index
number now this is different than
vlookup in vlookup you have column index
number and here you have row index
number so what are you interested in
searching for so we are interested in
searching for salary now in our range
that is basically the fourth row
remember we created a range from
employee name to salary so let's give
the row index number which is 4 and the
range lookup will say 0 which is
basically exact match and that completes
our formula so click on OK and that
basically gives me the salary for Eden
Connell now that's basically because we
have fed in the value here
and that is basically giving me this so
I can again do if error if I would be
interested in to basically take care of
error message if the value is not found
for that you can look into the previous
example which is vlookup now similarly
we are interested in finding out the job
title for employee ID
105 how do we do that so we need to use
Edge lookup well we could have done with
vlookup but here the data is more
arranged in the form of rows so how do
we do that so we can again use Edge
lookup but and we can give a range or
named range or let's for this time let's
basically key in our range manually so
we can do that so let's go for H lookup
now what do we want to search for so we
will say this is the value then we need
to give a range now as I said if you
would want to give a change manually so
for example I'll say a and then I'll say
a 1.
colon and then I'm interested in G and
then the row will be 4 so salary row is
not what we are we are not interested in
so let's say G and then we can give 4 so
that basically gives me the range right
instead of having a named range so we
can do that and then we need to give the
row index number so we are interested in
finding out the job title which is
basically in our range the fourth row
and then give 0 for true or false so if
you see here it tells if it is 1 it is
approximate match false is an exact
match and we can close this bracket that
completes a formula it takes the value
which is given in employee ID and then
it will try to search for the job title
so that basically shows wherever the
employee ID is 105 the job title is
fabricated again you can use if error
wherein your if error can then be
working on hlookup and can take care of
error so that if an employee ID is keyed
in for which there is no matching value
then it will not show you a not
applicable error in instead of that it
will replace with the word whatever you
have specified so in this way you can
easily use Edge lookup to search from
the range of data which is horizontally
arranged and in the previous example we
were seeing how you use vlookup when the
data is arranged vertically
so we have looked at vlookup and Edge
lookup and what we have seen is vlookup
has a limitation in one way that we need
to basically give a range where the
leftmost column is the one which is used
now instead of that we might be
interested in searching in specific
columns and not all the columns well
that can also affect the time taken to
search for the data
wherein we can select particular columns
or particular ranges rather than
selecting all the data which has to be
searched for so for example we have this
question find the salary of Hank
Saunders now that's the employee name
which we have here and we would want to
find out the salary so what are the
columns we are interested in so one is
your employee name and one is your
salary and these are the only two
columns which we are interested in so
instead of using vlookup now like I've
shown earlier you can create a named
range for these two columns and you can
use that or we can manually give the
range here so let's go for lookup
function here and lookup function will
basically help us in searching what we
are interested in so we are interested
in finding out the employee name
and we are interested in finding out the
salary based on the employee name so how
do we do that so here in lookup I can
first give the value which is here
employee name now whatever
employee name is keyed in here we will
be searching for salary of that employee
now lookup function needs a lookup value
so we are searching
based on employee name then it says
lookup Vector so we will basically then
say what is going to be our lookup
Vector so here we need to give a range
so what are we interested in we are
interested in finding out the salary
based on employee name so first goes our
range
based on which we need to search so
that's your employee name so let's for
example select this one so that's our
range B1 to B21 so that will basically
have the employee name in which we will
be searching for and then we are
interested in searching out the the
result Vector that is basically the
column from which we want the value
that's our salary column so let's select
this and that completes our lookup
function so now if you hit on enter it
shows that for this employee where the
name is hunk Saunders the salary is 5400
now you can test it by basically giving
some other name so for example if I
replace this with say Fred Stone
and that basically shows me the value
for Fred Stone we can replace it to the
question which we have that is Hank
Saunders and that shows me the salary so
that's a simple example of Lookup which
allows you to search by selecting a
range of columns rather than having the
leftmost column which has to be
referenced similarly we have one more
question find the employee ID of this
particular email ID so we need to again
use our lookup function so we'll say
lookup now what are we interested in we
will search based on this email address
so I will select this then I need to
give that based on email address we are
searching the employee ID so email
address is in this column so let's
select this range and then we are
interested in employee ID so then goes
our result Vector so select this column
and that basically completes your
formula so close this bracket and hit on
enter so that base basically shows me
the employee ID for an employee with
this email address so this is how you
use lookup now as I've explained earlier
you can be using the if error and you
can basically see how
your index match can be used now here is
an example of if error so basically this
shows how if error helps so say for
example as I showed in your sheet1 so
check for employee James Bond if the
value is not present display not found
then what are we doing we are basically
nesting our vlookup
inside if error with a not found option
which basically says if the value given
in the cell H is not found then
basically
it will
display not found so here you also
notice that the range which has been
given has been selected that is B1 to
c21 now we could have used the name
range which basically helps us in
searching for multiple functions we are
searching for 2 that is the column
number 2 here that is employee name so
check for employee James Bond if the
value is not present or no so we are
basically just searching for employee
name here and then give your 0 or 1. so
that's basically usage of your if error
which I have shown earlier and the same
thing can be applied for your Edge
lookup also
now suppose you have been given some
additional questions for example you
know instead of using your vlookup or
Edge lookup or lookup examples what we
have seen say for example you are asked
to find the salary of Peter Daniels now
we already know how to find that using
vlookup right so for example we want to
find out the salary for this employee
name which is Peter Daniels I can use a
vlookup however sometimes we may also
want to use a index match an index match
is also one useful function to do that
so we can basically search based on that
so we have to define the range of data
we have to then say what do we want to
match so that's basically an employee
name and then we are interested in
finding out
say for example based on the range of
employees you would want to find out
the value of salary so we are then
giving a range and doing it how do we do
that so for example here I can use a
function which is called index and if
you see here it says returns a value or
reference of the cell
at the intersection of a particular row
and column in a given range so this is
where index function can be useful now
we can start with this function it says
it needs an array that's nothing but a
range so we can basically select all our
data so I can say A1 all the way to E21
so that basically is my range now I
would want to find the salary of this
employee name which is Peter Daniels so
I can use internally here
basically you need to give a row number
so what we can do is we can do a match
so we can use an internal function match
now we need to basically give it
correctly so we need to say match now
how does this match function work so we
need to basically match for a value so
for example we will select whatever
employee name is given here so that's
Peter Daniels now that's basically what
we would want to match
now where do we want to match this so we
want to match in the column B which has
employee
names so we can give a range which is B1
to B 21 so that's basically within the
employee names we are looking for a
match which is given here that's in H6
and we want to do a match so we want to
do a exact match so let's do a comma 0
and then we are interested in finding
out the salary
based on this match and salary is in our
fifth column so let's basically give the
column number here and then just close
this bracket
so that basically completes your
function and just hit on enter so that
shows me the salary of Peter Daniels
right so this is an easy way when you
can use the index function remember
first you give the range
and then you need to give your matching
conditions So when you say match I would
take the value whatever is given in this
cell I will search in the range of
values which is employee names I will
find an exact match and what I am
interested in is finding the salary for
Peter Daniels now similarly say for
example you have been given a question
find the employee ID with salary 10 000.
so you want to find out the employee ID
wherever the salary is ten thousand so
we are obviously looking for an exact
match now how do we do that so we can
start with our index function and within
index function we need to give a range
so for example I am interested in
finding out say for example our range
which is a 1
two
E21 so that's what I'm interested in or
you are actually interested in searching
based on
save your salary so you are interested
in searching the employee ID so maybe if
I just do a 821 let's see what happens
here now then I can just do a match
so match will be now done based on the
value which is here H 13 so I will do a
match for this one now I need to give a
range
so let's basically give a range which
will be we are interested in
searching employee ID based on the
salary column so that's your e column so
I will say E1 to E21 that's what I'm
interested in searching
finding a match for this salary we want
an exact match so first let's close this
one now
that's fine I mean we are interested in
finding out the employee ID based on the
match which is within this range
and then what we would want to do is we
would want to basically find the
employee ID employee ID is in my column
A so what I can do is I can additionally
give a match here and then I can say I'm
interested in the finding out the value
for employee ID
and that basically needs a range so the
range here will be just the
the column headings so we will give A1
all the way to E1 so that's the range in
which we would want to search and we
would want to find a match for employee
ID we want an exact match so let's close
this one and that basically closes my
match and we need to close our index
function so now that shows me employee
ID where the salary is 10 000. so this
is how you can do your index matches
where you can give a range then you can
say what you need to match
within which particular column whether
it is an exact match or approximate
match and then the column from where you
are interested in finding out the value
so same thing we did here we basically
gave a complete range and if you closely
see we were only interested in finding
out the employee ID so here I give a
range A1 to a21 which is basically this
particular column so that's where we are
interested in finding out match
basically will give your lookup value so
that's h13 then we gave a range which is
salary that's what we are interested in
and then we said when we are doing a
match we are only interested in finding
out the employee ID
which is in a range of column names and
then doing an exact match so this is how
you can use index match instead of
lookup which can also give you uh some
exceptions in searching for specific
columns or specific rows now if error we
have already discussed where you Nest
your vlookup or hlookup inside it
so this is how you can use your lookup
functions Edge lookup vlookup lookup or
index match to search for data some
function like this which shows up
xln.xlookup and then you're trying to
search for something so don't be
surprised with that so xln is basically
a prefix added to functions that don't
exist in the version of excel you are
using you have Excel 2013 and say your
friend has a newer version of excel say
Office 365 or Excel 2016 and basically
he uses a new cool function and sends
the file to you so that's where you will
have this excellent prefix as I am
showing up here so for example what is
the job title of Xavier power is what
you would want to search and here the
function which shows up Excel and X
lookup and then you are searching so
this is is basically something which is
the function now if I just select what
it has selected here and if I hit on
enter it shows that this does not work
in my Excel here and that's because of
the version but what I can do is I can
fix this by removing this
details here
and that basically shows lookup we are
searching for job title based on
employee name which is in this field H6
and then we need to give a range so we
need to give a range of names employee
name and then basically the job title
range which is basically the job title
so now if I just hit on enter it gives
me the value so it's as simple as that
similarly here what is the employee ID
of the person with this email we have
already looked at the lookup function so
if it shows your xln X lookup all you
need to do is remove this and then keep
the lookup function searching for the
value based on the range of values and
then searching for a value within a
range of values so just hit on enter and
that gives you the value and same thing
goes for this job title so what is the
job title and salary of employee name so
we have this function now what I can do
is
here I am interested in finding out the
value for this particular function how
do I fix this I can basically select
this and then just do a lookup based on
the values and it basically says you
can't change part of an array so we can
fix this now what we need to do is we
need to basically search based on this
particular value so we will basically
say I want to do a lookup now lookup
should be based on employee name
whatever name is given here then you
need to find the job title and salary so
for job title I want to find based on
employee name so I will give a range
and then basically I will say I am
interested in finding out the job title
so I will give a different range
and then basically close this so that
basically shows now this is basically
because of the
function which we have here so basically
to fix this what we will have to do is
we will have to delete all the columns
here which were selected such as
employee name job title and salary
because that was giving you an error you
cannot delete a part of an array now
what we want to do is we want to find
the job title and salary based on the
employee name so we can do that using
lookup as we have done earlier so we
will use a lookup function now what we
are interested in finding out is the job
title based on employee name so we can
select this cell which does not have any
value
then we need to basically say from which
range or based on what you want to
search so we want to search based on
employee name
and we want to find out the job title so
we can basically give a range of values
and then we will be interested in
finding out the job title so let's
select the job title range and that
basically completes our lookup so let's
close this and hit on enter now it says
obviously error because this does not
have any value we will fix that by
giving in a value here same thing we can
do for salary so for example I can just
drag and drop it here and in this one
instead of
basically having a range which is your
we will be interested in finding out the
salary so
let's see what is the range we give so
the range should be employee name so we
will basically select employee name as
the range
and then we are interested in finding
out the salary so we will select this
particular range and what we are
interested in finding out is basically
employee name
or we are interested in finding out
based on employee name so let's select
this particular column and then hit on
enter so both of these are any values
now just feed in an employee name so we
will say for example Eduardo and that
basically gives me the job title and
salary so that's how you can fix your
Excel FN error so same thing goes here
so it shows you xln is what you would
want to search might be if you don't
find something you would want to
pushing name not found so first is we
will have to fix this part so we will
have to remove this because that's not
supported in my Excel and then I have
lookup I'm searching based on h24 which
is basically employee ID you are giving
a range which is A2 to 821 because we
would want to find name not found
for a particular employee ID so I am
giving a range which is A2 to a21 I am
trying to search for the name which is
from B2 to B21 and then I am giving name
not found so say for example we can do
this lookup but then with lookup you
don't have this direct option what we
can do is we can use if error
if error and then basically try to
search so that gives your lookup value
and then you will have to close this one
and then again if it gives you some
error like this we can obviously go for
vlookup and fix this so here we are
searching for a particular range and
then let's search for this value
and basically to fix this what I did was
I just use a vlookup so we know that
employee ID 121 does not exist so I'm
just using IF error I'm doing a vlookup
where I'm searching for the value given
in h 19 and then I am saying that I
would want to search from a range which
is basically B1 to c21 that is in
employee name and say email address for
example and we would want to basically
search for name not found so we can
instead of giving B21 or B1 to c21 we
can restrict it to just B1 to B21 we are
searching in column 2 we are searching
for exact value and if it does not fine
then it says name not found and that's
how we do it so we can always replace
and fix this Excel FN errors if
you are using uh some spreadsheet which
was or Excel which was sent by
um someone else who is using a different
version so in this way we can use your
different lookup functions take care of
your errors use index match welcome to
this tutorial on Microsoft Excel let's
quickly see some more examples of doing
data analysis using Excel and for that
we can use some inbuilt add-ins which
can be added to our Excel sheet so for
example if you would want to do a
descriptive analytics or descriptive
analysis on your data say for example
getting your descriptive statistics such
as your mean median mode and so on so we
can do that and we can use Excel for it
so for example you can if you are given
some data say I have temperature price
of ice cream units sold and I would want
to have descriptive statistics on this
what I can do is I can click on file and
here in file you can click on options
and within options click on add-ins now
within add-ins you have Excel add-ins
which is selected here so click on say
go for example and that shows what
add-ins are available and you can choose
which ones are you interested in so for
example I have chosen analysis tool pack
and solver add in and click on ok now
that basically should add more options
to your Excel so if you click on data so
here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis and here it says what are you
interested in there is a two-factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance descriptive statistics you
have histograms so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on ok now
this one basically asks your input range
so while your cursor is blinking here
also it is said grouped by so let's give
it a range so for example I will say say
temperature
now if I do this and I have selected The
Heading just look at that and now you
need an output range so let's just
select this and then you can have your
cursor blinking here let's select save
Fields here and this is where I would
want the output now it also said what
options do you want so it has output
range we can then select summary
statistics confidence level so I will
say summary statistics is what I'm
interested in say okay and this says
input input range contains non-numeric
data now why is that because we chose
temperature The Heading also so click on
OK and here we will alter the range so
this one is our range should be only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics and now you can
click on OK
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here I could basically
given a value for this so I can say
temperature and that's my descriptive
statistics for temperature might be I
can just do some formatting and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here now
similarly we can do it for price of ice
cream so what we need is we need to
basically go for data
data analysis descriptive statistics say
okay now you need to give a range so
here I will change my range to these
values output range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on OK and this says
output range will overwrite existing
data press ok to overwrite data in range
I will say cancel no that's not what we
want to do we need to give a new Range
so let's select our new Range which is
here and now click on OK so now we get
the values which is for your price of
ice cream so again we can basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier I can select this I can
basically do a merge and center and that
gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this now I can go into
data and I can go into Data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this B2 to B8 and this
one which is H6 to h19 we would want to
shift it might be two columns up so
maybe I can just say H5
and I can manually change it to a 17 and
let's say okay
and
we will basically get this and I can get
rid of this so I can have it in the same
range so similarly so this one will have
to be renamed and I can basically say
price of ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units sold so we would
want to have this now let's see we can
click on data we can click on data
analysis descriptive statistics so we
need to give the range correctly so this
time our range changes to units sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if we were selecting The Heading so
let's do it in this way so in my range
in my range let me empty this I can
basically select this which we know has
non-numeric data in the first row say
for example I'll say labels in first row
I am interested in summary statistics
and this range will now have to be
changed from H to basically something
like J so let's say J and let's select
these values so that should take care of
things and now you see you have your
unit sold you did not have to manually
rename it
and you have basically got the
descriptive statistic so this is how you
can simply perform analysis using data
analysis here you can basically get your
descriptive statistics for your columns
and then you can do whatever needed
formatting you need to basically make
your data look
in a
good way now let's look at one more
example of data analysis where we may
want to look at the frequency of values
or frequency of values occurring in a
range of values so for example if you
have been given temperatures you have
been given some pins where you would
want to identify how many values fall
into the range of 0 to 20 20 to 30 30 to
40 40 to 50 and the easiest way to do
that would be creating histogram now
histogram is usually used for data
analysis where you would want to look at
different variables or say features for
example temperature is one such feature
might be there might be one more
variable or feature such as sale of ice
cream and you would want to see if the
increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be sale of ice
cream is a is a response based on
temperature so it depends so sometimes
you may want to find the relationship
between two variables whether they are
positively or negatively related or you
would want to do different kind of
analysis and in certain cases we may
want to First do analysis on one single
variable look at the frequency of values
might we also look at the defects and
for which we can use something like
parrot or chart so we can go for
histogram and that basically gives us
the frequency of values now how do we do
that so we have already added the
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay now I have already
selected input range so if you see here
my input range is temperature which is
also with the headings and I have bin
range which is basically the range of
values so for example I can select this
and that's my pin range I am selecting
or the option labels because I'm using
the first row which has the heading such
as temperature and pins now we need to
give a output range so for example let's
say I would want my data here and that
becomes my output range so you can have
a sorted histogram or basically a Pareto
chart so if that's what you are
interested in looking at the frequencies
for your different ranges and here I am
also selecting chart output because I
would want to have a visual histogram
which gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on OK and now
you get your pins so it basically tells
you frequency of values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the value is 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20 so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we
can basically say there is 120 here with
the 20 being the maximum value and then
there is one more 20 so that's your 0 to
20 then you have 20 to 30 which shows
three values so might be in that case I
can say 26
is one thing then I can say 30 that's
the second one and then basically I can
look at 22 so basically this one does
not select 20 as the lower range but it
basically selects 30 as a higher range
so I do see 20 to 30 there are three
entries similarly we can see values of
40 and 50 and since we have selected
Pareto or sorted histogram that shows in
a descending order what is the highest
frequency of values within a particular
range
so that shows me highest frequency is 5
and then you have three and three and
then two so this is how we can create a
histogram and we can perform an analysis
on a single variable
now
as discussed earlier as I said sometimes
we may be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to
find out the correlation between one
variable to another variable or we would
want to find out the relationship
between variables are they linearly
related are they positively related
negatively related and so on and for
that we can use the correlation of your
data analysis add-in so for example you
want to find out correlation of
temperature and units sold and what we
can do is we can find out that using a
formula so for example if I search for
something like Co relation
and let's search so there is a function
called correlation which we can use and
we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me and first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select the range of values
for temperature and then I am interested
in finding out the correlation of
temperature in units sold so let's
select this and that basically gives me
a range of values it gives me the
correlation value which is 0.2859 say
okay and that's your value
so similarly we can do it for
temperature and price ice cream so let's
go for
correlation so that's the function we
are interested in you need to give a
range of values so here we are
interested in temperature and price of
ice cream so let's select temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of ice cream let's
select that let's close our bracket and
here we have the correlation value of
temperature and the price of ice cream
similarly you may be interested in
finding out temperature and units sold
like what we have done earlier so we can
do the same thing based on function so
this is same as correlation of
temperature in units sold so I can get
rid of this one now how do I do it using
the data analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into Data we need to click on data
analysis and here you have the option
called correlation let's select this now
that basically needs an input range so
we need the range now I might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
I've selected all the columns here we
will say Group by columns obviously we
need to select labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading now output
range you can just give one simple cell
and that's where your data will start
from or you can give a new workbook so
click on OK and that basically gives you
that basically gives you a correlation
of your different variables and what are
the values and we can check these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically temperature and price
of ice cream
and that basically shows me
0.96149 you have temperature and units
sold so you have 0.2859 now you can also
look at units sold and say for example
price of ice cream you can look at these
particular values so if I would be
interested in finding out what is the
relationship between these variables I
can easily find using correlation so I
could be basically writing in a formula
here and selecting what are the cells so
here we were selecting A2 and C here we
were selecting A and B now might be I'm
interested in price of ice cream and
units sold and if that's what I'm
interested in then I will give a range
of B2 to B8 C2 to C8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values so it's very simple in Excel and
you can use either the data analysis tab
and get your correlation or you can use
formulas and do that
now one more important part of data
analysis is doing your sampling now
sampling could be periodic sampling or
random sampling so sometimes you may
want to look at a variable and you may
want to
get some values based on periodic data
that means might be I am interested in
range of values I am interested in
seeing a sample of values for
a particular period which could be
basically
a range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if I go
for periodic sampling so out of these
values which I see here might be I want
to see say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or I
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly I would want to pick
up say three temperature values now how
do I do it so for example here I have
seven values now if I go for periodic
sampling
the sample or periodic sample value
which I need to give has to be lesser
than the total input values
so for example we can do this let's go
in here and let's go for data analysis
so we can go for sampling here click on
OK and that needs a range of values so
we will select a22 A8 now I could have
selected all the values for this one
temperature and in that case I can give
labels which is going to take care of
the first
row now here we can go for
number of samples which you are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
I have seven values so what if I select
five so for example if I say 5 that
means
I could just get one value so basically
when I'm saying 5 out of 7 so that's
just giving me out of five I want one
value so I can then just give an output
range so here I can basically select the
cell I'll say okay and now you see it
just shows me
one value
so out of the first range that is I have
said 5 it has given me the fifth value
that's your periodic sampling so for
example we want more values so let's
reduce this period to might be 2 which
basically gives me every second value so
I can basically say for example 2 and
say OK and then say okay so that shows
me 26 then you have 35 then you have 40
and then well this one does not have any
more values so that's your periodic
sampling now if you go for random
sampling that's basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want so go
for data analysis go for sampling I'll
go for number of samples how many you
want so for example out of seven values
randomly I want three values
and I can just give this say okay and
then
we will do a cancel because we need to
change that range so let's select this
and say okay and that gives me random
three values from this values of
temperature so we can use Excel to do a
simple sampling and we can choose
whether we would want to go for periodic
sampling or random sampling let's
continue learning Excel and how Excel
can be used for data analysis now we
have seen a sampling histogram
correlation descriptive stats and now
also let's look at regression now what
is regression so when you talk about
statistical modeling regression analysis
is used to estimate the relationship
between two or more variables and
basically we would want to look at two
or more variables and basically a
relationship of those variables with the
response or the Target right okay so for
example if we look at our data here we
have temperature we have price of ice
cream and then we have units sold and we
can go ahead and make predictions so for
example when you look at regression here
you see something like this which is
regression statistics you have Anova you
have different plots which we have here
which is X variable X variable 2 and
then you have normal probability plot
now we have already seen how you can
have your add-in that is data analysis
which helps you in doing different kind
of data analysis here right now how do
we do this so we have our variables here
which is temperature price of ice cream
units sold and when we talk about
regression we need to understand which
one of these are independent variables
which one of these are dependent
variables right so when you talk about
your X that's your independent variable
or we can say predictor or explanatory
so when you talk about your independent
variables or as we say predictors or
explanatory variables these are the
factors that might influence the
dependent variable and when you talk
about dependent variable that's your
response or Target that's the main
factor you are trying to understand or
predict so we can plot a scatter plot to
see relationship between variables if
they are linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on we can also get values such as
R square which is coefficient of
determination regression line and then
analyze the relationship between
variables so here is one of the links of
one of my edit other videos where we are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression but that's programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
Spark now here let's see how do we do
this in Excel so basically we would want
to use our variables which is
temperature price of ice cream units
sold and then get these plots so what we
can do is for example I can get rid of
this
and might be I can just say
no borders and when it comes to these
plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal using your data analysis
add-in tool so we have been given
variables here now as I said when we
talk about your
regression analysis we need to
understand whether we have one variable
or we have multiple variables right so
you might have heard of univariate
analysis by variate analysis and so on
well
here we are focusing more on using Excel
to do our regression analysis so I'll
not go deeper into regression topics but
certain things as Basics should be known
that when we talk about regression
analysis what does it do it helps you
understand how the dependent variable
changes when one or more independent
variables vary and it basically allows
us to mathematically determine which of
those variables really has an impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model that is based
on the sum of squares which is basically
a mathematical way to find the
dispersion of data points so mainly the
goal of the model is to get the smallest
possible sum of squares and draw a line
that comes closest to the data so that's
what we mean by our regression line or
basically looking at the points and
seeing if the points fall on a
regression line if there are residuals
that is points which do not fall on the
regression line and in terms of
statistics
when we talk about
statistics we differentiate between a
simple and multiple linear regression so
you have something called a simple
linear regression models which basically
gives you the relationship between
dependent variable and one independent
variable using a linear function and if
you use two or more variables that is
explanatory variables to predict the
dependent variable we are actually
dealing with multiple linear regression
so if the dependent variable is modeled
as a non-linear function because the
data relationships do not follow a
straight line we have to use non-linear
regression
now what we will do is we'll see how we
can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this might
be based on temperature price of ice
cream we would want to find out how many
units were sold now what we can do is we
can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot which is quite easy in
Excel so if you have been given
variables what you can do is you can
click on insert you can then choose the
kind of plots which you want then here
you have insert scatter plot so we can
choose this and you can choose the first
option so that gives you a blank layout
and what you can do is now you need to
select data so for example let's click
on select data and then you can say add
so what we would want is we can give a
name so we want X values and we want our
y values right so when you talk about
why that's your dependent variable or
your response or Target so that is in
our case units sold and X values are 1
set of features or variables or multiple
variables so here I can click on this
series X values and then I can select
this
now in y values what I can do is I can
select these and then I can just say
Okay so that shows me that it would be
giving me a regression scatter plot now
let's say okay and we have some points
plotted here now if you would want to
see the impact of one individual
variable such as temperature or price of
ice cream you could as well do that now
what you can also do is you can add more
meaning to this by giving in a title or
you can also go into Quick layout and
you have various options here so you see
it gives you what is the access title
what is the series and I would prefer to
use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your R square and that gives you
your Y and X that is your coefficients
so let's select this one and then we
have some values which we can use to
compare this also shows me the
regression line and you can keep this
for reference if you would want you can
change the chart title to something else
say scatter plot of uh dependent
uh West independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning and we can get
rid of this one so we have series and we
can say what are these points if you
would want to add in Legend if you would
want to do that or I can just get rid of
this and I will keep these values here
which we will
see when we do a data analysis we can
always compare these values so here I've
created a simple scatter plot
and then I can look at dependent West
independent variables
or I could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my x-axis what is my y-axis so
basically you can hear
say for example just say Y and might be
here I will say x and we can rename that
later now how do we perform data
analysis or get into regression right
now what we would want to do is
we would want to get or we would want to
do the regression analysis to
demonstrate the relationship between
dependent and independent variables so
normally when you talk about your linear
regression equation you might have known
about it so it is basically why when you
say y
equals you can say BX plus a plus c and
this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression where X is your independent
variable Y is your dependent variable
your
a is the y-intercept
which is expected mean value of y when
all X variables are equal to 0 so
basically on a regression graph that's
the point where line crosses the y axis
and that's your intercept
when you talk about B that's basically
your slope of regression line which is
the rate of change for y as X changes
and then you also have
your constant right so that's your uh
sorry that's basically your random error
term right which is basically the
difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value so your
linear equation
always has an error term because in real
life predictors are obviously never
perfectly precise right now what we can
do is we can also reduce this
equation to Y is B X plus a and that's
the equation of a line we can look into
this and the linear equation can be
understood mathematically in this way
now how do we do it in Excel so what we
can simply do is
here let me
yeah
so we need to get into data and then
here we have our data analysis add in
you can click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression so that's what we would want
to do now we'll say okay now here you
need to give your input y range so as I
said you will have to select the
dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here and here we
have your X and Y so y being your target
that's basically your unit sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to X either you can select
one variable or multiple variables so I
will select temperature price of ice
cream and then since we have chosen the
headings we will go for labels right now
we can always look at the confidence
level we can change that so you can say
whether you want it in a new worksheet
or you can just say output range and I
will probably just click here and select
one of the cell here now we can also
choose the other options which we would
want to see as a part of this regression
analysis so basically we have selected
input y range which is your dependent
variable
you have selected X range which is your
independent variable and if we are
building a multi regression model then
we
have chosen temperature and price of ice
cream both
now we can choose the labels which we
have done we can choose your output
range which is basically on this sheet
and then we can select the residuals so
that basically gives you your residuals
now we can also get your line fit plots
which you were seeing earlier you can
also go for your normal probability
plots and then basically just say okay
and let's say okay and that basically
gives you your regression analysis
output so we
basically have your summary output we
also have Anova we have our serial
output that's from the previous one and
basically we can get rid of this that's
not required
I can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics we also have our plots so we
can basically look into these so we have
our normal
let's get rid of these
let's get rid of this let's get rid of
this and then what we can do is since we
had some existing data it has
overwritten so let me get rid of this
and I'll repeat this step again
and let's say no water yeah
so now what we want to do is we want to
do a reaction analysis so we go get into
Data we get into Data analysis we choose
regression
we have already chosen our y range which
is column c x range is multiple
variables we have gone for labels output
range which we would want to select a
particular cell so let me select this I
am going for residuals line fit plots a
normal probability plots and say okay
so now
we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah and that basically shows you the
variables so here it shows me units sold
and then what are the predicted units
sold and here the variable is
temperature here the variable is price
of ice cream right so that's your one
variable and second variable and then
you also have your normal probability
plot now to interpret this or to
understand what we have here where we
look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what Excel is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
Excel it is performing all the
calculations automatically the
interpretation is something which we
need to understand so basically we are
looking at multiple r value here and we
can
let's also fine tune this one
here we have our values here and if you
see we have our R square now we can then
basically look at our multiple R so what
is your multiple R that's your
correlation coefficient which basically
measures the strength of linear
relationship between two variables so
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient it can be any value between
minus 1 and 1 and its absolute value
indicates the relationship strength
so the larger the absolute value the
stronger the relationship so 1 basically
means a strong positive relationship
minus 1 means a strong negative
relationship and zero means no
relationship at all now when you're
looking at R square that is the
coefficient of determination which is
used as an indicator of the goodness of
the fit so it basically shows how many
points fall on the regression line so
your R square value is basically
calculated from the total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared deviations of the original data
from the mean
now when we talk about looking at the
value of your R square so it is
basically we can be seeing uh that this
is
0.450788 that's the value which I am
talking about so it basically means 45
percent of our values fit the regression
analysis model so in other words 45
percent of dependent variables that is
your y values are explained by the
independent variables that is your X
values
so normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit and here we have considered multiple
variables now when you talk about your
adjusted R square it is the R square
adjustment for the number of independent
variables in the model so uh you would
want to use this value instead of R
square for multiple regression analysis
such as in our case now you also have
standard error so that's basically
goodness of fit measure that basically
shows the Precision of your regression
analysis so the smaller the value the
more certain you can be about your
regression equation so when when we talk
about your R square that represents the
percentage of dependent variables
variance that is explained by the model
and standard error is basically an
absolute measure that shows the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so you will have to
look back into regression statistics
terminologies to basically understand
more of this and if you're already from
data science background that then you
already know what I'm talking about we
are just seeing how Excel easily helps
us in doing these things now we can also
look at observations here which is
basically the number of observations in
our model which is seven
now when we talk about regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your Anova values here
so we basically see DF you have s s m s
f and significance F now to understand
these so basically what we are doing is
or what Excel is doing is it splits the
sum of squares into individual
components that give information about
the levels of variability within your
regression model so when you talk about
your DF that's basically the number of
degrees of freedom associated with the
source of variance you have sum of
squares that is your SS so smaller the
residual SS compared with the total SS
the better your model fits the data
right now when you talk about Ms that's
your mean Square you have f is basically
the F statistic or you can say uh f-test
for the null hypothesis basically it is
used to test the overall significance of
the model and then you finally have your
significance f which is the P value of f
so uh when we when we usually talk about
simple linear regression the in Anova
part is not really used or it's rarely
used right but when we look at the
significance F value that gives an idea
of how reliably or statistically
significant our results are so if
significance f is less than 0.05 that's
5 percent our model is okay if it is
greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent variables
right now we can also look at the output
of coefficients and that's what we would
want to look at so you basically have
your intercept here so when you talk
about your intercept temperature price
of ice cream so we know we are looking
at our variables and then we are also
locate looking at our intercept which
basically gives you
more details on your coefficients so the
the main important thing when we talk
about regression analysis is basically
your coefficients it basically enables
you to build a linear regression
equation uh in the form of y equals BX
plus a which I explained earlier and
then basically we can understand our
regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output which we are seeing here
so that gives you your observations how
many observations we have it shows what
is the predicted units sold and then it
also gives you your residuals so we can
compare the estimated and actual number
of sold umbrellas based on the
observation so we have
11.209 here and if you compare that's
basically 12 the second one is 15 and
here it is 13.5
you have and similarly you can compare
all the values of actual units sold and
what our regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these and
we will see if there is any difference
or no
right so obviously there will be or
there would be some difference because
independent variables are never perfect
predictors of your dependent variables
and the residuals
basically help us in understanding how
far the actual values are from the
predicted values so that's what we see
here in the residual section so for
example when we look at this one which
is 11.209 and the actual is 12 we see
what is the residual and how far is the
predicted value from the actual value
so similarly we can also look at the
percentile values so that gives you your
probability output and this is what we
have in our graphs
so we have basically our variables we
are looking at our variables and also
the units sold and the relationship
between them we can basically uh add in
more details to this particular plot and
you also have normal probability plot
which is basically getting your values
from your probability output here so
this is how you can perform a simple
regression analysis and now what you can
do is you can as I said you can
basically be looking at your scatter
plot you can be looking at your y and x
and your R square values right but
remember what are the variables which
you are selecting and then you can
compare these with basically the values
what you see here so remember here I've
chosen my both set of variables and you
can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact on the response or on the
target
so it's pretty simple here you can add
more details to your scatter plot or the
plots what we have created or Some
people prefer to do it using formulas so
basically we have some statistical
functions that can help you do linear
regression analysis such as you have
linuxed you have slope you have
intercept you have correlation and so on
so basically you can use these
particular functions and what you will
have to do is
you will have to basically go in for a
function if that's what you would want
to do and then you can search for
functions and say for example I'll just
say lynnest and say go and here I have
my function so if I would want to really
use this one I can do that what I will
have to do is then select the variable
so if you just say okay and that
basically says your known Y is known X
your constants your stats and basically
you can use the formula also but we are
not covering that here might be in the
later videos we can do that so just try
out and perform some regression analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that so
that basically gives you
an easier way of Performing regression
analysis using your data analysis add-in
in Excel now with that we have come to
an end of this session on who is a
business analyst and business analysis
with Excel if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you require the
resources that we used in this session
then do let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be more than happy to resolve all
the queries at the earliest until next
time thank you stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here